good morning
just to give you the lay of the land
today we will be addressing House Bill
639 and we'll be getting it done
we I am going to open up the exact
session and then I will immediately
recess it until 1 30 today
and then we there's a bunch of
amendments flying around that severals
have never seen so we'll then use the
next hour or so to talk through those
maybe do some straw poll votes just to
see where people are at
break for lunch and during the lunch
hopefully we've got good bipartisan
consensus on where we end up and we come
back at 1 30 to vote for a yes that's my
goal we'll see how it goes today so yes
sorry you said immediately recess
but on we need a little time to explain
why the amendments are there yes so
we're going to open it up we're going to
recess it then we're going to do work
session for about an hour hour and a
half then we'll break for lunch come
back and then exec hopefully around 1 30
ish we'll see how quickly we will not
have the final Amendment
my amendments I I told oh okay so what
we're going to do now we're gonna we're
gonna go into work session effectively
for an hour hour and a half to talk
about all the concepts that are floating
around right now because I don't even
know what they all are and we'll talk
through them quickly I do want to be
efficient with our time today we have
had a very long work session and we've
done a lot of great work
we're going to keep that going we want
to kind of get to some decisions here so
that this afternoon we can definitely
execute with whatever amendments we
think can fly okay and then of course
anyone can always do a floor Amendment
too but I would love to see what we can
get consensus on here on this committee
so I do see two substitutes here today
so welcome
um let me just open the exact session
recess it and then if you don't mind
just do a quick introduction so all
right so this is my gavel we'll open up
the exact session on House Bill 639 and
then we will also resource it until 1 30
today
okay
welcome representative Heinz what's your
real name
thank you madam chair my real name is
representative Erica Leon from Derry
excellent representative Rome yes I'm
representative Rosemary rung from the
town of Merrimack which is Hillsborough
12. and who are you substituting for I
am substituting for representative
Schamberg
welcome to Ways and Means and thank you
for participating with us okay so the
one amendment I am
sure of because I've actually seen it
and I heard about it is the one that
came out of the work session last week
that was worked on by everyone here but
has the name Doucette and spillsberry on
it it has number
1182h on it
and again we're not an exec session now
we're in a work session but I am going
to see if one of those two members could
talk about this amendment and explain it
to us
representative spielsberg
thank you madam chair
uh
so for the most part this amendment
represents a faithful effort to
incorporate uh the Crux of discussion
and where we seem to be settling last
Tuesday
um
if I can just walk you through it
make sure everyone is on board
um
if you have the amendment in front of
you Representatives
11 11
8 2.
I've got uh yeah excuse me one one eight
two I'm sorry 1201
okay so 1182 appears to have been handed
out
does not have here it changed it's the
most recent one
thank you
but what's the difference
okay so there's a I guess there's a
revised version which is the 1182 is
that the one we you want us to look at
it
I'm seeing 1182 for the first time it
appears to be identical
782 it's March 22 and the date on 1201
is March 24.
and I've seen 1182 for the first time so
um
it does not have this 1182 does not have
the change that you made on page two
most recently at line 24. I'm not quite
here
it does not have the change that you
made most recently which is should have
been a should be at page two line 24.
22-24
yeah 22 to 20. yes that that which I sat
around on Sunday hasn't been
Incorporated by OLS yet so I'll address
that yeah it's not here that's right
okay well okay so walk through one of
them just pick one and walk through it
and then because it sounds like no
matter what we're gonna need to make
sure there's some corrections
I think they're the same just quickly
looking through them
um so
the First Amendment
which runs lines 1 through 21.
could not be simpler
it simply is changing online 21
the little letter
C becomes a d becomes C
and it's realigned that's all that
Amendment does
moving to the Second Amendment which
starts on line 23.
I withdraw this amendment this was a
policy change and I'm gonna remove it
what it related to was the question of
opt-in versus opt out the bills that
came to us from the Commerce Committee
is a opt out provision meaning
municipalities would have to have a
local vote to uh to not participate and
not allow a facility so we're just going
to strike that second amendment
the third amendment
begins at the bottom of page one on line
31.
but carries into page two
this is again very technical
on line six
we've truncated the sentence so that
we've dropped a final phrase that real
that referred to an obsolete a
non-existing statute
Amendment
or
online 11 you see the first two words
are the commission
and all that's done is drop the word
cannabis
commission is a defined term
back on page three
or four
so so those amendments are purely
technical
amendment five begins on page two line
14.
and runs through Page Three line nine
this is
the reallocation of how the funds will
be distributed
and in a nutshell
it shifts this from being primarily
focused on reducing the unfunded
liability in the retirement system
to fifty percent of the total for
Education thirty percent for retirement
10 percent for DHS five percent for
Department of Safety or safety uh
entities and then another five percent
so that the final three are targeted
programs uh just as Ways and Means had
determined them last year
and I believe that everybody was on
board with this change on last Tuesday
the
the modification that I will make when
this goes back into a to OLS today
is on lines 22 to 24.
and inadvertently language was taken
from a different source that wasn't the
final
iteration of what we did last year in HP
15 98
and that final iteration I'm referring
to is exactly identical to what you find
in this year's bill so if you look at HB
on page 22
wait till you get there
on
on 22
this long provision starts with the idea
that if the retirement fund is fully
funded then it goes to education so the
words we want to restore
begin towards the end of line two and go
to the end of line eight and that is to
say
the percent shall be dispersed to the
education trust fund
the Comptroller shall notify the
commissioner of the Department of
Revenue administration of the amount of
the transfer
for the purpose of setting the education
tax rate under RSA 763 the amount of
Revenue required to be collected
pursuant to RSA 76 3 shall be reduced by
the amount transferred to the education
trust fund is required in the
subparagraph
and the commissioner shall set the rate
at a level sufficient to generate the
reduced amount this rate shall be
effective for the following fiscal year
so this was inadvertently left out this
is the the passage that we were
discussing when Kim Wong from the dra
asked the question about the timing of
the rate adjustment
and representative fellows and I were
specifically going over this language so
I'm simply going to restore this passage
into the amendment
and the thrust of it is this
the language inadvertently used
effectively says that
um the proportionate amounts will be
sent to the municipalities
like a cash disbursement
that wasn't our intent what this
language does is it makes it clear
that the the
amounts attributable for each
municipality
will simply be recalculated by the dra
when they set
the swept rate for that municipality so
it becomes a credit that reduces
the amount of money that has to be
raised by that community Through sweptex
the but the money the cash stays at the
state
okay
um
so over to page three of our Amendment
the sixth amendment begins on line 11.
and runs to line 25.
and this is the section that relates to
the tax itself
and this incorporates all of the
discussion and wordsmithing that we did
last Tuesday
so that it makes it clear that this is a
excise tax
charged at the wholesale point where the
sale is made
to the retail store
the taxpayer
is the Cannabis cultivation facility or
the Cannabis product manufacturing
facility that has sold their goods and
the tax applies to their monthly gross
revenue
um I did add one little phrase
on line 15
subsequent to our discussion last
Tuesday and that is I inserted in their
final form
that's the phrase that the commissioner
used repeatedly
so it doesn't make a difference whether
it's something coming directly from a
cultivator in a raw form to the retailer
if that's its final form or whether it
was converted into some kind of inedible
that's its final form
I think there was a question
and you just you've just done a nice job
giving us the highlights of each of your
amendments and then we'll go out and
take some questions okay so so again
this is exactly as we worked it out last
Tuesday with the exception of that
phrase in their final form which I think
just helps to clarify exactly what it is
we discussed
Amendment seven starts on page three
line 27.
this is the last of these amendments
and what this does is it reconciles
that the use of the term biennium
which is the way that it's used on page
so that the
hundred thousand dollars in line 29 and
the two million dollars inline 34.
are a two-year appropriation
I would just mention also
that I saw this morning before heading
in that representative Ames
has found several technical errors
basically citation flaws I've looked at
them he's absolutely correct and I don't
think it's even worth discussing here
but where he's he's found a reference to
RSA 318 f24 it should be 318 F21 I've
reviewed these they're accurate and I'll
just incorporate them into our amendment
I think that's the smoothest way to do
it is that good with you okay thank you
for that high level overview now I'm
sure you have lots of questions
representative Almy
and those those Errata are in my
environment as well uh which is more of
a technical Amendment but it's uh
attached to what the medical treatment
centers want
which we they haven't been able to
present because
we never get to them before they have to
leave
and that's the same thing is going to
happen today by the way okay
um but um there are throughout here
including in this amendment there are
references to the liquor and cannabis
Commission
which The Liquor Commission which
doesn't seem to be present uh very much
wants
fixed because they have to completely
separate their liquor operations from
the Cannabis operations
just in case someone comes along to be
president who wants to
to crack down on cannabis
so good if you look at page four
line 16.
commission is a defined term
a mission means the liquor and
just to clarify you're looking at the
original bill
I'm looking at 639 yes okay yeah just
sorry we got confused a little for a
second there
uh so so from from that definition every
reference throughout the rest of the
bill should simply say cut the
commission
is that essentially what you were saying
we need to I'd missed this one too in
definitions commission means liquor and
cannabis
somehow
I missed that one I think representative
Platt
I'm just a small suggestion on line 14
will says you say a tax on the monthly
Etc which page page three line 14 of the
amendment yeah you see a tax on the
monthly and this goes on yes why not
insert change a to n excise
thanks make it clear I'd be perfectly
fine with that both in line 13 where
there's a caption and in line 14 where
it uh
I mean if if that's the consensus I
think that would be a wise idea
which page page three is the amendment
lines 14 is what
okay representative elberger
thank you madam chair
um some of you hopefully all of you have
seen this uh on the table in front of
you firstly I want to be clear that I am
not a mathematician and I'm really bad
at spreadsheets so there are three cells
that I need to give you corrected number
that's under 30.
on along the top where it says sales and
millions 30 the first line is 2.4 the
next line is 3.3
the next line is 4.5 and the last line
in that section is 6.0 can you I will
read it again
we're on under 30.
it's the column across the top says
sales and millions under 30.
the first line is 2.4
the next line should read 3.3 then 4.5
and 6.0 and my apologies as I said
math is and spreadsheets are not my
skills what I've been trying to do
instead of saying well I like this
number and I like that number is figure
out what it will actually cost to run
the commission
so what I did was take a look at sales
and millions across the top means sales
and millions of dollars of product that
are sold at whatever level at whatever
rate the retailer or the wholesaler
chooses it's just what the sales are
and then looking at tax rates on the
column on the left
looking at eight percent 11 15 and 20
percent
then the numbers in the cells on the
interior there
indicate how much revenue
will result from for example in the
first cell if retails if sales at
whatever level as I said are 12 million
dollars taxed at eight points uh eight
percent the revenue from that is 0.96
million so nine hundred sixty thousand
dollars
uh if it's a 18 million dollars in sales
at eight percent one point four four
million Etc
um
if the commission requires
4.2 million dollars every year
just for the ongoing maintenance of the
commission
then
we don't get anywhere near that at eight
percent
until and I didn't get this in until we
have sales of 53 million at whatever
level
so
53 million dollars whether it's at
wholesale retail seed whatever level
we're looking at we need 53 million
dollars at eight percent just to cover
the cost of running the commission
we're also coming in with at least 15
million dollars we being the state
coming in with at least 15 million
dollars that the commission will have to
repay the state for startup costs I just
again played with numbers and said if we
try to add two percent uh the 2 million
to the 4.2 million this is the stuff at
the bottom
um if we need to make 4.2 million
on 12 million dollars annual sales the
tax rate has to be 35 percent
these are just the numbers
uh if we go up to 36 million
we need to have a tax rate of 11.67
. so what I'm trying to do here is say
instead of just saying I like this
number I like that number what do we
actually need to run the commission
even before we look at revenue for the
things that we're talking about
providing money for Education money to
cut down the retirement commitment that
we have and all the other pieces that
we're talking about and based on this
particularly if we're looking at
sales uh doing an excise tax at the
wholesale level
we're going to need to be
getting a whole lot of Revenue that I
don't see that we're going to get
15 comes a whole lot closer it's not
great but eight million eight percent to
me just doesn't make sense based on
these numbers and I'm happy to answer
any questions that you may have I know
my brain works one way other people's
brains work differently
so
um I think as part of the spillsbury
Doucet Amendment there was a
contemplation of changing the rate to
eight percent
it based on your analysis what would you
recommend
15 at least
thank you representative
yes have we had any estimates of what
revenues might be from uh sales and
millions not our revenues but sales and
millions might be for New Hampshire
compared to other states and our
population
I I certainly haven't I did a quick
check with May on Main because Maine's
population is roughly similar to ours
and their retail sales in 2021 were 82
million and in 2022 159 million but that
was at the retail level
not at the wholesale level
representative yes thank you madam chair
just to answer representative plett's
question when Vermont did this and
opened up their stores I think it was
October their first month's Revenue was
just under three million dollars uh I
believe so um and I think they had
supply issues as well so that's I want
to say it was 2.75 and they were running
out of product so assuming that they
have plenty of product I think you can
make an estimate considerably higher
than that
so I think we heard oh did I miss a hand
up here so okay I think we heard that
there are lots of Concepts in here there
are some technical reference Corrections
citation Corrections that need to be
fixed there's a couple of OLS errors in
here
but you understand the underlying
concept here so I'm thinking it might be
worth taking a straw poll just to see
where we are on this amendment as a
whole and go from there if there's broad
support or enough support
then we know and we can go on to the
next Amendment all right so yes other
things representatively could I ask a
clarifying question absolutely
um I'm on the spillsbury Ducette
Amendment page two
line 23 where we're talking about the
distributions on the education
supporting education
and
um my question is you clarified
that the municipalities would receive a
credit
um and that the money would stay at the
state so I just want to think make sure
I'm thinking about this correctly so
basically 50
of the revenues
would be directed at education but
is another way of saying that that where
that money is going is is actually it's
not really to education it's to relieve
property taxes
for municipalities
am I getting that right that's that's
exactly correct
um
so I believe you and I uh maybe it was
rep elburger and I made that observation
and then
um representative Ames later echoed it
this doesn't increase education funding
this finds a new source to help
alleviate the extent to which education
funding Falls further on the real
property tax via the swept by reducing
the swept
can ask a follow-up question so so um
and again this is just a part of the
revenue we're generating right it's not
the entire Revenue 50 right so an
important part of it so an important
part of the revenue for this bill
isn't really Revenue right it's not new
revenue for the state it's replacing one
source of Revenue
um with another one so it's not
increasing Revenue to the state it's
making it so the cities have to
contribute less
to the state so I I'm trying to think
about
what the bill does in a couple different
ways so I'm thinking that we're
discussing an excise tax and we're
trying to figure out what the rate is
where we're going to stick it but one of
the big things it does is not generate
new Revenue but
relieve
property tax pressures on citizens
so we we need to be careful about the
semantics it generates new Revenue
from a new source thereby allowing us to
make a judgment
that we can reduce the amount of Revenue
that we need to raise
through the swept
by surcharging the real property tax
and I have to say if if I was in a
conversation with
any of my constituents they don't view
the swept tax as a state tax technically
it is but it's collected on the back of
the real estate value
it's collected in the town it's paid
together with their real estate bill
and it's retained in the town and then
turned over to the school district so
yes this is allowing us to make a
substitution
so the
place where I'm trying to arrive with
that is I think we all share the the
point of view that property taxes are a
pain point for our constituents they're
very high and we all would like to lower
them and this bill does that in a small
way
and as we adjust the rate that we're
discussing
it might do that in a bigger or smaller
way as we adjust that rate between like
eight percent fifteen percent wholesale
retail so I just want to add that to
kind of how we're thinking about this
um that that is one of the variables
that
it's a direct impact
um in that way that is a little bit
different than when we usually just talk
about
generating Revenue I just want to make
sure I was thinking about that right
before we proceeded representative
Southward thank you has his things
standing up for you
um as a follow-up so what happened in
the previous budget we did take was it
50 million a year towards reducing swept
it was 100 million per year
so as a as a taxpayer that didn't have
much effect on me that I could tell in
meeting with my city manager and going
over that impact our school costs
actually did go up with less state aid
um but also this will be a lot less than
a hundred million a year that's going to
help the taxpayers so it just just
seemed to me that it's a very small
amount
um and unless I'm doing the figures
wrong
representative Ames
I was actually asking um representative
spilsbury well I can come in go ahead
and comment representative Ames and then
we'll see if there's others yeah I think
the point is well made that um if
let's I think this is optimistic uh
Mystic to say that we'll be able to put
20 million dollars into that 50 that
allocation that goes to swept relief
20 million dollars
of 363 million dollars it would be
reduction from 363 million is about a
seven percent
reduction
of the swept rate the swept rate
equalizes a dollar 44 currently
for a thousand
so you take seven percent of that you're
down to something like
0.1 uh at ten dollars per thousand
no I'm doing it wrong 10 cents for for a
thousand or somewhere like that you get
a small amount I I'm not going to try to
do it in my head but and then you
multiply it by let's say a hundred
thousand dollars you've got a lot of
trailer homes in your town I know that
that are at low values or maybe uh in
other towns let's say three hundred
thousand dollars you get maybe ten
twenty thirty dollars of tax relief it's
not much
okay we're going to take a straw poll
soon there's a whole bunch of hands over
here we'll go back around and then we'll
take a straw poll representative orrs
thank you madam chair so if Maine is
selling at retail 82 million in 2021 and
159 million in 2022
through to covid it would seem to me if
initially we started at 15 at the
cultivation grower level
as we come up the food chain like The
Liquor Commission recommended and we tax
excise tax whatever you want to call it
on the final form product we are going
to need less tax
and I also want to remind everybody from
the information we have provided that I
asked
I think was the head of the Cannabis
group here in New Hampshire about where
did they get their stats from they
provided some pretty good stats and if
we legalize cannabis it's gonna take
away cannabis from youth because it
should dry up the black market and they
would have to buy it after retail market
so we need to remember that I think it's
more important that we keep cannabis
away from children
by legalizing if we're going to legalize
it and the revenue is not that important
I mean if we didn't legalize cannabis
there wouldn't be any Revenue so there
will be additional Revenue but I think
it's more important to dry up the black
market and keep cannabis out of the
hands of the youth thank you
representative Elber
thank you
if we're looking as this bill
points out that the tax rate will be
imposed at the wholesale level
we've heard from at least one source
that
you need
three to four times
at the wholesale level to make what you
would get at the retail level
then again just looking at Maine from
last year when they made 159 million
dollars in retail sales and divide that
by three we're looking at about 53
million here which is barely enough to
cover our commission costs
so we're not seeing anything to cover
the debt to provide any kind of relief
for swept or anything else and
um to shift gears and follow up on
representative leapley's comment the
cutback on
property taxpayers of swept however much
that rate would be
if the state has to absorb that into the
360 million
363 million dollars in the education
trust fund Whatever Gets absorbed that
there unless there's some other Revenue
will mean lower
funding for other programs
at no let me try that again play with
numbers if we get 20 million dollars to
go to relief to taxpayers
on the swept level we are still
committed to 363 million dollars for
sweat for the education trust fund
correct
that means the difference has to be made
up by general fund sources unless it's
coming up from somewhere else
I don't know if they take 20 million out
where that 20 million comes from
okay I want to keep going around the
room quick comments clarifications on
this before we stop we'll representative
putt question on the straw poll you're
about to take is that for all of the uh
what's before us in this amendment uh
21182h plus some minor changes that we
discussed Inc including the uh eight
percent rate or was it other than the
rate it is this amendment with all the
technical Corrections that were
referenced
as is with all the technical Corrections
okay
yeah rates right here so it's all of it
including everything in here with the
technical Corrections that
representative spielsberg identified
okay so just so we can see where we are
on that representative aim Matt
Madam chair
might I suggest that we if you're going
to do a straw poll I know we all have
different uh positions or figures in a
head we can talk about the amendment
with the technical changes and leave out
the component of the tax rate
for the straw poll because I don't know
that we'll get a true pulse of what the
committee wants to do until such a time
we come to an agreement where we should
be in that
and moreover just just to some of the
commentary that was made here any tax
relief at least for my constituents any
tax relief is good tax relief it's it's
if it's 30 or 40 dollars I know that
that buys a couple boxes of diapers or
whatever and I know that may seem Petty
to some people but to some of the people
that I speak to it's important tax
relief so we we can't solve the problems
of the world with one piece of
legislation on one Revenue Source but we
can start cracking at the seal
okay I promise to keep going around this
way representative all me is on now good
yeah yeah on
first on when we look at 150 something
million for Maine
they are undoubtedly taking money from
Massachusetts and from us
that is Incorporated in there at this
point they are a tourism destination
um
so I would more believe there are 82
million but Maine taxes at three levels
they have a cultivator tax they have an
excise tax and they have a sales tax
we have no way at this point of finding
out what pers what part of that Revenue
is simply the wholesale tax
the excise I presume that's their excise
tax
um
and we have this problem with all the
other places that we're looking at too
we should have started working on this
last summer when they worked on the
other parts of the policy but they
didn't invite us
and um
it's so we're
whistling in the dark pretty much tax
Foundation said 44 million for New
Hampshire we have no idea how they got
that number
based on what but um
the size of the dartboard that's pretty
much where we are and that's a shame for
a Ways and Means Committee but that's
what we've got to deal with we got this
bill really late in addition to the fact
that we should have started on it last
summer but
um I also
uh I've forgotten
what the rest of my comment was so well
keep in mind I know we're all trying to
do our best best job to get this as good
as possible however we all know
there will be opportunities for new
bills next year as we learn more about
this and as we move forward there's
probably going to be bills every year to
keep tweaking this to get it to be right
for New Hampshire okay we do have a
problem
of basic policy which is whether this
bill as it was created by the people who
put it in on provides at least some
significant money for something outside
of paying for the Liquor Commission to
do this
and eight percent at wholesale level I
don't think does more than pay for the
Liquor Commission to do it once they've
been going for a while
okay other hands up here before we take
the straw poll and because we got other
amendments guys representative
thank you madam chair just follow up on
your swept text
um can't use props on the floor but we
can here
360 three million dollars
if I take
10 million dollars
put it in here as well
then that overflows this and that that
overflow goes back to the taxpayer it's
still
363 million dollars if it's 20
in then 20 out
going back to the taxpayer so there's no
reduction it's still 363 million dollars
so there's no reduction
one can only hope that that's only water
in that vessel that you just handed up
okay moving around representative did
you have representative Leon yes thank
you very much um I I think that
representative Almy brought up a good
point about some cross-border travel
that's happening now
um the Massachusetts cannabis Control
Commission reported about 1.5 billion
dollars in sales last year and our most
populous areas are on the border of
Massachusetts with our more populated
areas having easier travel into
Massachusetts so I don't think that we
can put a number on this but I don't
think that that 1.5 billion dollars in
sales should be ignored
representative fellow sorry it took us
so long to get back around to you
um yeah because
well I would like to get to the straw
voting on all things other than where to
tax and how to tax in the amount of
money
I'm very good with the rest of the
amendment that that representative
spilsbury has and I also want to say
that how he described what happens with
the swept tax is accurate I worked at
the Department of Education for 30 years
all of the time involved with that
formula and while you know whatever
amount amount when we go back to the
words that were in the original Bill to
describe the swept what happens is
similar to to what happened last year
when the swept tax was cut from 363 down
to 263. you may not have noticed it when
you looked at your whole tax
Bill property tax bill but it did indeed
reduce the amount of money that
people had to pay on their property tax
for schools by
not not exactly 100 million but probably
80 million and I won't go into the
difference between the two but it does
indeed reduce what is on the property
tax bill
thank you very much okay what I'd like
to do is just take some straw polls here
we will as recommended oh go ahead
representative I just want to clarify
you mentioned that we're we're
bracketing the tax rates are we
bracketing where the tax Falls because I
think some of us are still trying to
figure out between retail and
wholesale uh well the amendment before
us is not on retail it is on the final
form so at the wholesale level am I
correct with that yes so this so this
amendment which we are about to vote on
um bracketing off the tax rate is on
it's an excise tax effectively not a
retail tax representative I would point
out that a lot of the policy has already
been decided on the house floor
and to try to change it now to a retail
sales tax isn't going to fly that's a
policy change
but what we did with an excise tax we
didn't really change policy even though
it was sold as wholesale the word again
it said referred to manufacturers as
well so it was it was clear we didn't
okay
so Mr clerk help me help me count
because I can't see everyone very well
so Madam chair yes
um can we please vote on everything
except related to where where the tax
Falls and the rate of that tax
and just get all those other issues off
the table because I have an amendment
that I'd like to propose that that moves
moves it farther up the chain
for the level of Taxation
um well let's see where we are with this
because this is what we have before us
and then I don't even know how many
amendments there are out there and we
can we can see where we are on that as
well representative already
just as a reminder regarding policy and
procedure
if we come up with an amendment and then
we come up with another amendment the
Second Amendment modifies the First
Amendment so you can keep changing
things Bit by Bit by Bit by Bit until
you get what you want
yes and if we end up with you know at
the end of today before three o'clock
hopefully um if we end up with three
different amendments that pass this
committee then they'll all be merged
together into one I do understand that
but I would like to
have a discussion of that will impact
how much money we raise from the from
the taxation
which can legitimately be placed either
at the wholesale level or a higher level
I'd like to have that I just like to get
everything else off the table so we can
discuss just that
representative balmy
yes I think if we do as of some fellows
says and vote separately on the tax rate
and location
from the rest of the amendment that we
can at least clear out the rest of the
Amendments policy from the other debate
because otherwise you'll have a lot of
us voting against the rest of that
policy
okay so we will do three straw poll
votes on what I have as Amendment 1182
is that the amendment number we're
looking at
I guess so
it's actually 1201 that we are dealing
with but so far as I can tell 1182 looks
identical okay so there's three
different straw poll votes the first one
is
the amendment as produced with all of
the corrections that representative
spilsbury has identified
not including the tax rate
or where the tax is imposed upon all
those in favor of that raise your hand
I can't see what it's economics
how many how many people is that though
please then it's 20. okay 19. oh
yeah who's missing
well that's why I need you to see it
okay
so who's so I apologize
okay second part would be on the tax
rate
right now in this amendment what is uh
entertained is an eight percent rate all
those in favor of the eight percent
raise your hand
help me Comfort
nine one two three
oh God
um
all those opposed
ten
okay so how many people do we have in
this room here
it was 11. I probably do it again how
many opposed please could you raise your
hands again please three four five six
seven eight nine
uh on the eight percent rate
are you opposed to that or do you
support that you're a post put your hand
up for a second okay just double check
okay
so Tyler post but we had nine that were
for it so we'll try that again who was
four okay okay all of those uh in favor
of the eight percent that is in this
amendment
five six seven eight nine
yeah
okay all right and now the third element
of this amendment is
what was discussed what would the seem
to be is this part of this amendment is
to keep the tax at the excise or
wholesale level
with some clarifications on the right
wording
representative fellows just my
understanding is that an excise tax can
be at any level so I think that's right
I I think the question is your question
would want to be do you want to keep it
at the wholesale level is that what
you're asking yes sir okay so all those
in favor of keeping it at the wholesale
level please raise your hand
all those opposed to the wholesale level
taxation
six seven eight nine ten
okay Madam chair question yes
representative is wholesale level
considered final form I just want to
make sure that confusion I'm I'm
confused on that one I or let me say I'm
just looking for clarification is
wholesale level considered final form
what is exactly stated in this amendment
I'm using the word wholesale because
it's clearer than
because it's not necessarily at the
farmer level right it could be at the
producer level does that make sense
that's what we clarified here at the
final form am I right good okay exactly
okay so now we know that we don't have
consensus on the tax rate or where the
rate is imposed
representative Platt Madam chair I
suppose I suggest we
discuss where it's imposed first because
it may affect the rate
I said I suggest we talk about where
it's imposed first because whatever that
decisions will affect the rate
Madam chair you
um I have an amendment okay that puts it
at a different level
can I I pass this around sure
mm-hmm
separating faces
okay everyone has it now so can you just
describe what this does
okay no one has it so we all know about
the New Hampshire advantage
and we don't want to see a sales tax
and a sales tax is something that you
see if you're a customer on the receipt
so what I've proposed here is it a tax
on the product when it's farther up the
chain so it has a higher value but it's
not imposed on the customer
and what it's called is a gross receipt
it's a it's a tax
paid by the
the company that owns the retail
establishment and it would be a tax on
the gross receipts of the sale of only
those products that contain
cannabis and and the rate I put in here
is 15 but we can talk about that next
so this is
um it's not a completely unique idea I
actually found this in New Mexico's
um process for taxing cannabis they I
think they
I can't remember the details of that but
it's it's it's not um something that I
just made up other states use attacks
that's called gross receipts
so maybe we just talk about that concept
okay let's real quick talk about that
concept and then we'll go to straw Provo
just to see where we're at so we're just
going to keep drilling down okay yes
representative if it's at the retail
level it's a sales tax even if it's paid
for by the retailers it is not a sales
tax and I just told you a sales tax
shows up on the receipt for the customer
and this is not a sales tax
representative Spielberg
thank you madam chair
um
so
I I think it's a fair distinction a
retail tax is tacked on top of a a sales
tax is tacked on top of a retail price
and excise tax is embedded into the
price
excise taxes are generally charged at
the wholesale level they can be either
so you know I don't want to get caught
up in those semantics I think
representative fellows is essentially
correct
but my argument for
doing this at the wholesale level
would be number one I want it to be an
excise tax so that it's invisible to the
customer it's embedded in the price and
I think we agree on that
and second
what we're doing here is we're
legalizing something that has been
historically illegal
we're allowing something that in many
circles is still objected to
we're taking something that has been out
of favor
and we're allowing it to be in favor in
fact we're capitalizing on it the state
is actually planning to generate revenue
and that's the essence of our discussion
I would be happier
taxing the Cannabis in its final form
before a retailer marks it up I don't
think that the state
should take a stake
in how much the markup is
I think as we heard in testimony last
Tuesday markups can be all over the
place they can be different radically
different for one form of the product
relative to another
or one store relative to another one
Outlet
and one chain of just channel of
distribution from another
let's leave the amount of the markup
to the competitive Dynamics
let people compete and it's probably in
the interests of everybody that they
compete sharply and I I I simply do not
see any realistic possibility in a
competitive Open Marketplace which is
what we have not had
but we're creating
of a 300 or 400 percent retail markup I
don't even want the state to be in that
game I want to Simply tax it
before the retailers compete
representative Doucet it's a couple of
representative spilsbury said
in effect in simpler form
there may be a time and there may be a
market for say people that want to have
a cannabis infused wedding cake for
instance okay
and if it gets a sales tax a retail
sales tax
that
conservatively speaking thousand dollar
wedding cake with ten dollars twenty
five dollars worth of cannabis product
it's taxed at a thousand dollars
it makes far more sense to tax it at the
wholesale level than to put this on the
retail buyer because they will pay for
it they will pay for it
okay I'm going to keep going around this
side then we'll come around and then
we'll do our vote representative leapley
thank you
um this committee has been provided with
a number of different
uh lists of what other states do and
where the tax is imposed
and there are a number of other states
that impose excise taxes and these other
states also are states that just
have sales taxes right so every example
I can find
um
every other state
and the reason that I'm considering what
other states do is because we don't have
any information
on Revenue generation in this state
right so it's it's easier to look around
there are a number of excise taxes they
are paid by the retailer on gross
receipts
some states also impose taxes on the
cultivator or on the manufacturer but
the the way that I see it we can tax
this product at a lower level than any
other state in the Union
and do that on gross receipts which
would be paid by the retailer
um
and still undercut every other state
without shooting ourselves in the foot
and wondering if we're even going to
cover our costs so I'm not sure where
the advantage is I see that there is an
advantage the New Hampshire advantage
of taxing lower we do this with
cigarettes we do this with alcohol and
we see real advantages for our citizens
so I guess I'm confused on where the
eight percent comes from and why we're
choosing to impose it on the wholesale
because it feels like we're on purpose
not just foregoing some Revenue which I
think we're all fine charging a lower
tax rate than anybody else who is next
to us I think where you lose some of us
is we don't understand why it's so
out of whack with everybody else's
approach to taxing this product and
there is a cost to society just as there
is with cigarettes and alcohol and it
worries me that we are willing to forego
so much revenue
I would agree with attacks that would
undercut
all of our neighbors but would be at
least on a realm where we can compare
which because every other state has a
retail tax or a retail gross receipts
tax we could at least compare oranges
and oranges so I'm in favor of a low tax
I'm in favor of having a tax that's
lower than all of our neighbors I just
would like to be on the same chalkboard
as we discussed this thank you
okay over here I'm representative Elber
yeah
um one of the thank you madam chair
one of the
we're looking to tax somewhere and the
question is are we in effect
are we taxing the consumer or are we in
effect looking to impose another
business tax
because if we tax at the excise level
we're taxing the businesses
we've got a reputation as a business
friendly state
I I have a hard time sorting out
which way we want to who we want to
annoy uh on some level
one I'm not proposing this but if we
want to make sure not to try to spread
the annoyance around we can do some on
each level
I am not proposing this
but
putting the tax on a wholesaler is a
business tax
and we should just be aware that that's
what it means
representative Orr thank you madam chair
so
I would like to see I'd rather see the
tax at one percent I mean if we want to
dry up the black market
that's the goal as far as I'm concerned
drop the black market you take cannabis
out the hands of children and others
that can only get it through the black
market I don't care if the cost to the
state is x amount of dollars for this
commission or that commission or this
fee or that fee
my only reason I would support this at
all because of the societal impacts is
that we dry up the black market I don't
care what the revenues are to the state
I don't care if it's a million dollars
10 million 100 million 200 million a
billion or one dollar if we dry up the
black market and help our youth and help
our society
and take away the impacts that cannabis
is going to put on our society just like
alcohol and driving and talk while
intoxicated that's what I'm concerned
about I'd rather see the tax at one
percent so we compete out compete all of
our neighbors and dry up the black
market on every side of our borders and
within
okay going to this side of the room
going around going around representative
wrong I'm sorry
uh to that point I just want to remind
you that the lower we tax the retailers
are still going to price the product at
what as a competitive level so it the
question is
um do we want to take more of that
profit and tax revenue and leave them
with less or give them more in tax more
in the profit that's really what the
question is because
they're going to price it at the same
amount whether we tax them at one
percent or eight percent they're gonna
they're gonna their price is gonna be
driven by what the market is can can
absorb so I just think we have to
realize that just because we may go to a
lower tax doesn't mean the final price
to the customer is going to be lower it
very well could be at what we would
charge at eight percent they're going to
sell it for what they can the money they
can get for it and that's going to be
the highest number that the highest
price they can get and so we would just
be driving more of their profit if we
tax less it happens in the state with
gas prices our gas tax is pretty low but
uh relative to Massachusetts and so gas
stations closer to the Border can charge
more because as long as they charge less
than Massachusetts does
so that I just wanted to make that
clarification representative Southworth
thank you I tried to resist but as an
education educator this bill does not in
any way help children right now teen
parties have marijuana and alcohol
easily available and after we finish our
votes they're going to uh I think it's
just going to be easier for them to get
edibles and things like that that other
people buy legally and the idea of a
teen party with lots of Edibles where
people aren't even sure or what they're
eating makes me very nervous thank you
thank you representative Ulrich thank
you madam chair
if we think about how a business
operates
in order for it to come out to a sale
price
there's a lot of factors that go into
that but let's take a a meal at a diner
we have the meals and rooms taxes added
on afterwards so that's a point of sale
tax
however
the cost of the
server the cost of the line cook the the
cost of the soup cook the head chef or
manager all of that stuff is built into
the cost of the individual meal that is
set down in front of you
if we look at this in the same fashion
when you put the tax as we do with the
business Enterprise the business profit
tax front loaded as a cost of doing
business then the business knows what it
can sell the product for eventually and
knows that everybody that is
selling this in a retail level as saying
is as has already paid the same that
they have on the product that they're
selling regarding the depending upon the
tier and all that stuff but for the same
product the same egg is going to cost
this or across the board
so by putting it on the front end you're
aiding the business by setting up the
cost for them to do business
whereas on if you put it at the top end
it depends solely upon how much money
the person has who wants to buy it not
upon the cost to sell it and that price
at the end
at the sale
uh
is is totally dependent upon cash flow
that's where other states have made
errors and have not been able to drive
the black market out of business
and as was stated on the floor the other
day arose By Any Other Name is still a
sales tax
represent Allman did you want to say
something yes couple of things on
one if
we had a sales tax a tax uh an excise
tax at the wholesale level that was
equivalent to an eight percent excise
tax at the retail level on it would have
to be 46 percent
that's the difference that we're talking
about if you want to do this at one
percent there is no way that the Liquor
Commission is going to be able to do any
of the work
so on and if it only pays for the Liquor
Commission program then you're going to
to remove
any benefit including the education
component that is done by the HHS
treatment centers on
from from the bill
so
on and the policy of the bill included
spending this enormous amount of money
we don't have on all of these other
things and we've made it somewhat more
reasonable with the amendment
on
we
if we're going to do this we are going
to add to the difficulty of people who
are trying to get people not to use
cannabis on
but
we are not going to add
to their ability to combat it or the
ability of of
the people who are using cannabis to to
um
get their lives in order
not speaking is I'm kind of neutral on
the effect of cannabis myself having
been subjected to huge amounts of it
when I was in graduate school
I just happen to be immune to it so I'm
neutral
but on
but we do we do need to at least make an
effort to produce some of the money that
the people who put this bill in we were
leaders of both parties
wanted to see come out of it
and on a eight percent
wholesale tax comes down to about two
and a half three percent at the retail
level it is so much below any other
state that we probably would get a fair
number of people
buying over here but we'd also be losing
money while we were doing it
okay we've gone around once we can go
around again you missed me when you I I
didn't see your hand up so go ahead and
then we'll go
thank you the first thing I'd like to
say is that unfortunately
legalizing cannabis is not going to get
rid of the black market it in other
states it has just made it worse it
makes you know more cannabis floats
around and people will you can't really
distinguish one from the other you know
after it's in the consumer's hand
and
one of the problems with trying to tax
at the wholesale level we heard about
this from from people who testified is
that some of the people who want to get
into this Market will have an integrated
system they want to grow the Cannabis
themselves process it themselves and be
the retail outlet for the for the
product
so there's a whole big problem of how
are you going to term determine the
value when it's integrated like that
another issue is that the price of
the the raw product the flowers
um is highly volatile
uh and it's it's a commodity it's
subject to fluctuations and fluctuations
due to the weather but also with the
amount of cannabis that's on the market
and what other states have seen
when they first start up selling
legalized cannabis is that the price at
the whole tale at the wholesale is quite
High and as the cultivators ramp up
their operation and they become more
efficient and more jump into the market
the the price of can the wholesale
product goes way down and because
they're competing among all the other
producers of the Cannabis when you get
to the retail level that's a whole
different business decision I mean
you're not selling the product based on
what you paid for it you're selling it
based on what consumers are going to
willing to willing to buy it for you
know so that's really two very different
things that that are going on here so
I that's one of the reasons that I think
that we we really have and and when the
price of cannabis the raw product is low
our revenues are going to be extremely
low to tax it at eight percent even if
you taxed it at 15 which is in the the
actual bill now
um you're not you're not gonna haven't
have hardly any money you know we we saw
the estimate from The Liquor Commission
that just the startup costs will be 20
million dollars spread over three years
you're going to have to pay that back
and then there are ongoing costs they
estimate to be four million dollars a
year and that's in an attempt to to
address you know letting it get into the
the hands of children but if if it's
legal and a 21 year old can go into the
store and buy it you know the kids can
get it just like alcohol now you know
legalizing it doesn't keep it out of the
hands of minors thank you
we may be at a point that we could
literally discuss this for weeks on end
and still probably not get a full
consensus it's just one of those topics
that's the sense I'm getting from the
room so I guess what I'd love to do is
just a strop hole just see where we are
again we have two concepts proposed in
your Amendment one is to tax the retail
store that's one concept the other
concept is the 15 rate
yes I would I think that there's one
thing we could do we I think we have
three options in terms of where we tax
it
and maybe we can discuss that first and
then talk about the rate
I don't know this proposal and the three
the three options would be at the
wholesale
having the um gross receipts tax and the
other option would be having some of
each
oh
okay well let's right now we have this
amendment before us which uh
obviously proposes the gross receipts at
the retail store level I hope I've got
that right
okay
all those in favor of changing from the
original bill passed through the house
to this new place of the tax raise your
hand
six seven eight nine
okay so all those opposed just we make
sure we get our numbers right
one two four five six seven eight nine
ten
somebody missing we're still missing
who's missing
huh
did you count yourself I cut it myself
yeah
um
okay so did you vote for the change to
this new you vote against it so then
today 9 11. okay so now
no it's not
it's not okay we're gonna get better at
this part okay clearly raise your hand
okay so so we are going to take the
straw vote again so we're going to start
over this is do we change from the
original construct of the bill to tax
at the producer level and change it to
tax at the retail business level and
gross receipts excuse me Madam chair yes
you indicated in the first uh straw poll
that we would be taxing at 15. the
original bill that this was the one
premise
yeah
no no right now we're just talking about
where is the tax imposed and we're going
to do the 15 on a separate
does that make sense
are we voting on the representative
fellows Amendment no we're breaking it
into two portions okay at the retail
level please clarify at the retail level
at 15 is what we're voting about no
we're voting on do we vote at the retail
level thank you
but the retail level not to the cons to
the customer but to the store
yes the way she's describing it is the
gross receipts which is at the business
level right so okay so that's what this
amendment proposes can I make one
further refinement
let's pull this the concept that
representative fellows is uh suggesting
relative to this Doucet spillsbury
Amendment which captures all of the
conversation up to date about how uh to
tax at the wholesale level and that's
different that language is different
from what was in the bill is received
from Commerce
so I think that's the comparison I I
understand your the problem I just did
okay I apologize my my mistake there so
yes we've already agreed very almost
unanimously on the clarification that
happened with the spillsbury Ducette
Amendment so so this is now A New
Concept do you like this New Concept
better if you do raise your hand
six seven eight nine ten
okay all those opposed
[Music]
to make my job easier please
five six seven eight nine ten okay so
we're at an impasse there okay so now
the second part of this question is this
amendment proposes
the 15 tax rate
no does not
could you have a poll to see if anybody
might support having some at each level
sure we can do that
okay would you like to State your
proposal yeah this is just a straw poll
would any of you go along with having
um part of the revenue raised from
attacks at the wholesale level and part
of it raised from a retail gross
receipts tax so you're talking about two
taxes two taxes wine of water yes
shouldn't we if we're following
procedure vote on the 15 first because
that already was yes I'm trying to
accommodate representative fellows
though so she she has thrown this out so
let's take a quick vote how many of
those would want to double tax
raise your hands
one two
that's three three okay
so now we know all those opposed
okay so we can assume that 17-3 so now
we'll vote on the 15 tax rate
not on the retail gross
receipts but on
what was described in the spillsberry
juice said Amendment 15 on that
uh Madam chair yes
I think one question has to be settled
one way or the other before we get to
the rate because that will affect the
rate and and uh the the retail level is
a change from what past the floor
uh and so that's a policy change in my
view
representative Amy
on so is the wholesale rate that you're
proposing
is a change from the policy that that
left the Commerce Committee but it is a
tax policy that they did not
not a um their policy so
um I would just like to say that I don't
really care whether it's the wholesale
or the retail level but the tax rate has
to be adjusted if it's at the wholesale
level so that it provides enough Revenue
so that this is worth doing
besides
the effect or not of of whether it keeps
more of it out of the hands of the young
people it also we need the education to
go with it we we
have major needs in this state that are
not being met because we keep on cutting
the taxes
guys it could turn out that we just are
at an impasse and this will go to the
floor with a no recommendation I believe
most of us do want to pass something
here so I hope there is some ability to
compromise representative roachford yes
thank you madam chair just to piggyback
on what representative almi said so
I think we've all agreed that we wish we
had more time we wish we were being
involved in the process earlier we wish
you had more research but one of the
groups that came here and did has done
the most research was The Liquor
Commission
and and in you know they've pulled
several States they've looked at their
taxes the revenues
um you know and one of the things that
when they were came to testify they were
testifying on a 15 cultivator tax and
they said in no uncertain terms that a
that's a feasible way to to collect the
tax and B the 15 is would be adequate to
to accommodate their needs so what we've
done with the uh do set and the
spilsberry amendment is we've we've
listened to some of the the concerns and
I think that you know there's some
concern whether we should be getting
taxing at the retail level this splits
the difference as taxes at the wholesale
level
the tax rate is lower because which I
think there could be some debate there
um but I think it's important to to
recognize that they were they were
comfortable with with what was came over
from Commerce I I'm afraid that if we
start mixing things up and act looking
at retail taxing and gross receipts it
affects the model that they testified on
to the point where it's unattainable
just sending the
bill without any amendments to as as it
came to us to the floor if we can't
agree on
you know changes yes representative only
on
The Liquor Commission last year knew
absolutely nothing about cannabis
and we're but they were supporting it
because it was something that
was
needed to be done
uh
they
their biggest
thing in this
is they would like to be able to take
over the pricing because they do a very
good job of pricing on and there is some
nod to that in this amendment that we
haven't discussed yet
um but they are in the business of
selling things they aren't in the
business of uh keeping the price down so
low that that their expenses can't be
paid and I do not think that they
have worked not none of the people who
worked on this bill paid any attention
to to the mathematics of it
representative
I'm sorry representative lippley
thank you
um I think representative
um might be misremembering we've had a
work session and at the work session we
asked a number of people directly about
taxing at the retail level and it was my
memory that the Liquor Commission said
that that would be an idea that they
would support and a number of the other
folks that we asked who testified that
the retail price could be three to four
times as much as the wholesale price and
that that is the most transparently set
value most transparently set by the
market so I think we we may be
misremembering the testimony from our
most recent work session
the other point I wanted to make is that
it's true that this bills passed the
house
our job as Ways and Means is to put a
revenue figure to it that's anything
that deals with Revenue that's within
our purview so it it troubles me when
people say they don't care about the
revenue so maybe they'll recuse
themselves from voting on the revenue if
that's not something they're interested
in helping decide
um I think that we should go back to
what we've established we took straw
polls right so we've established that
we're tied on representative fellows
idea of moving it up to the retail
they're 10 4 10 against we've
established that the
the technical language we agree on
and I don't believe there was a majority
for the eight percent at the manufacture
rate so let's just acknowledge where we
are that's why we do stroppels and so
how do we move forward from here
representative elberger
thank you madam chair
we are not a policy committee
except in terms of
fiscal issues
so I think one way that
perhaps would help us to sort some of
this stuff out
is to I wanted to make sure I didn't get
missed
is to would be to
just have a conversation
irrespective of rate or location
of the tax
about whether it is our belief
that
the
marijuana
program for lack of a better term should
be at minimum covering the expenses of
the program and how much
if we agree on that then
move forward to how much might we like
to generate in excess of that for the
additional pieces that we talked about
if as my colleague here to the left
pointed out he doesn't care
about covering the cost of the program
then we should talk about that
if that is something that uh
a majority of the committee believes
then we don't need to worry about the
tax rate or its location at all
if we do want to make sure that we are
at the very minimum covering the
expenses of the program which is the
annual operating cost and The Upfront
costs that the state will be covering
then we need to figure out how to do
that but if we're not in agreement about
that basic idea
then the conversation doesn't happen to
have has doesn't have to happen at all
thank you
I apologize I missed representative you
said and just so you know because some
some people are hard for me to see if
you can turn on your microphone it does
I can see the red it does help me quite
a bit uh representative Southworth has
gotten very good at that thank you so I
apologize representative thank you madam
chair and and I agree with you we we
could beat this dead horse for a long
time we've established a lot of things
what we can establish is this we have
this bill in front of us that came over
to us from the house with an
overwhelmingly bipartisan position to
pass okay secondly we can establish that
New Hampshire in general the
constituency that we work for supports
cannabis legalization
enough said I'm not going to tell you my
personal opinion but I'm not here for
Fred Doucette I'm here for my
constituency thirdly that same
constituency has told us time and time
again I've signed agreements and I do my
work day to day to assure that we never
never no matter how you label it no
matter how you brand it
support as sales and or an income tax
we're at a point here where I think the
majority of this committee can pass this
forward to the floor for a vote and it
can go to the other side of the wall I
can assure you if it goes to the other
side of the wall with a sales tax you
are effectively killing this bill so if
that is your plan
kill it in Committee just say it out
loud Stand by Your Position doesn't it's
not my position my position is this
we tax it at a reasonable rate
I'm a reasonable guy if we change this
percentage to a differing percentage the
way we proposed representative
spilsberry and I proposed how it is
taxed at the cultivation and production
level
maybe we could come to an agreement
maybe we could work something out maybe
we can find something that works for
both sides of the aisle here but make no
mistake a sales tax is a non-staughter
it's dead in the water and you
effectively kill it if that's your
intent let's kill it off now why we
wasting our time
so
that that would be my position I would
be very open to looking at the
percentage at the wholesale rate but
I'll I'll motion to retain this if we're
stuck on a retail tax because it's not
going to happen or we can send it to the
floor
and and not complete our work as a Ways
and Means Committee
all right does it make sense to have
emotion keeping the the structure based
on the spillsberg you said Amendment and
proposing a certain rate that we can
vote on what rate were we thinking here
representative Platt
um I'm not wedded to eight percent by
any means uh I don't buy the argument of
two to four times retail that's that
works on a reach and that works on a uh
illegal market for sure but when it's an
open market with anybody any store
can do it I just don't buy that kind of
markup and so but I'm willing to come up
from the ape for sure uh and and uh I
was going to suggest nine to stop and
see how that flew
been up to over here so I apologize
um I'll go with ores because his was up
and then I apologize I will come over
here
thank you madam chair so first of all
rep leapley was correct uh
The Liquor Commission was talking about
taxing at the final product the
wholesale level and not at the
cultivation level so definitely she got
that right uh and I was about to say the
same thing although I am against
cannabis personally I don't mind sharing
that
everybody I've talked to in my community
is against it now I'm an old curmudgeon
I realize that I am not running with the
18 year old or the college crowd or
whatever crowd you might be but the old
curmudgeon school that I am part of
everybody is against it
however I was going to say that
I would support a nine or ten percent
tax if that's what it takes to get this
done at the wholesale final form level
thank you
okay the whole bunch of hands over here
I'm not sure which one was first
representative Ames well I hope it was
you I apologize I couldn't tell
yeah
um
so this is how I would chime in uh and
how I answer a couple of questions that
have been raised
um to all of us first is that I want
this bill to go forward I want us to
find a way to make it happen
um and I know it's really difficult
because we hold different points of view
and different perceptions of the reality
um and you know that's not going to
change because it's
obscure and hard to know and certainly
impossible to predict the future
um so that's the first thing I think on
sort of the gut sense of Revenue and uh
based on all that I've heard and that
we've heard together and that I've read
about and so forth
I I believe I guess it's a belief that
this bill whether it's uh at the retail
level or at what we're calling the
wholesale level but I'll refine that and
say as defined in the Doucette Amendment
will be sufficient most certainly to
cover the liquor commission's costs and
I would expect some more on that I
remain totally skeptical on the use of
swept as a vehicle but I'm not going to
slow things down
for that because I think the
um this the swept
well I don't want to go off on the side
on that but uh but basically swapping
one tax for another is not helping
education and this is advertised as an
education piece it's not it's not it's a
swap at the marijuana taxpayer will be
paying the revenue instead of the local
property taxpayer the people at the
school district the kids and so forth
will be getting the same amount of money
that is the same education so to pretend
that this is making education better
is a leap maybe it's a coherent leap
that somebody could rationalize but
that's the way I see it so that's the
background really
and so where I could I could arrive at
it's a little different from maybe what
you've
what one might think I could go along
with that wholesale level
um
defined again in the uh Doucet Amendment
um and
I could do so but certainly not at an
eight percent rate
um and what I would favor is a 15 rate
and one of the one other thing I think
that that's reasonable after all this
bill came to us as a 15 bill
um and it was on the cultivator only but
now we've added in the manufacturer
um
and
the other point is that we're not going
to see any revenue from this bill for at
least two years
you know it's just not going to happen
because you gotta do regulations you got
to set the greenhouses up you got to
grow the stuff you gotta process the
stuff and get it into retail and then
then it's going to go out we're actually
going to get probably get money a little
earlier if it's at the wholesale level
because that's going to come before it's
a retail level
um
and then the other thing that I would
want to see in this bill is in
representative fellows amendments
actually language that I put together
and it calls it it requires it's not a
call for it requires it's it's her sub
paragraph five
requiring that the commission study the
efficacy of the rating scope of the
Cannabis tax imposed by this section
and whether ingest adjustments may be
needed in said rate and scope in effect
is a direction to the commission this
cannabis and Liquor Commission to look
closely at this issue over the next
couple of years
and thereafter and every every October
thereafter file a report with its
findings and its recommendations and by
that time the the commission will be far
more expert than it is now the world
will have changed a little bit and if in
fact it's true that a
attacks let's say as my my version but
it's on wholesale at 15 is just not
going to produce enough to cover costs
well you can bet the Liquor Commission
is going to be telling us that and even
if they don't we can figure it out and
in October
we can file bills
and seek to change it make it more
sensible
um so I think it's time to correct any
bad mistake if that happens this
language that I have would force that
the only change I'd make
no I don't have to change it because
it's right here
um it starts out October 1 2024 which by
the way is when before they're going to
get any money but that's all right
they'll look at the situation and make a
recommendation and uh and they can do so
before they start collecting them so
that's that's the picture that I paint
of what I would find acceptable if we
could find some way of putting it into a
motion that has that those elements in
it I would support it
I'm going to keep going this way because
I've done all of these so let me make
sure I get these two folks
representative ulrey and then we'll go
with this one thank you
thank you madam chair
so if Heinz I have no problem with
another report from an agency I mean you
know
it's just more paperwork for them to do
um
which just fine
but you're saying 15 percent
is the lowest you'll go or you'll go no
higher before negotiating right now
let's just get your point yeah well
that's my point
we need to find a compromise Point
someplace between 8 and 15. and I need I
think we need to get there some
pretty quickly
representative Southworth then
representative Doucet
um a couple of things clarification from
the chair
um so if for example we had no
recommendation it still would start on
the floor with ought to pass
yes and then also if we didn't if we
were still 10 to 10 on the Amendments it
would go to the floor with no amendments
correct and so the house would just
re-vote on it we took a look at it we
didn't change it and it would pass again
correct I'm just trying to sound a
little dire over on the other side I'm
not sure we do have to retain it because
if we didn't do much today it would just
go back the way it was the house could
pass it again it would go over to the
other body is that correct
I believe that is correct thank you
representative Doucette
please yes my constituents are split
um but I can say uh absolutely that all
of my constituents expect this to be
taxed they're not going to be surprised
at all with alcohol and uh cigarette
swing taxed that marijuana would be
taxed to they're expecting it to be
taxed the people who are for
legalization so I'm not really worried
about that part what you name it anyway
thank you
representative who said I know you had
your hand up I apologize no no worries
in in in the vein of getting some
progress here I I respect what
representative Ames said and agree that
you know we shouldn't be stuck on one
number or another
I also with the uh the fellows Ames
amendment I would be in total agreement
that that section five be drafted in
because it should be reviewed and it
should be assessed and it should be
reported as to adjustments that need to
be made under this
um I also would offer this up for the
sake of moving forward and I'm not
negotiating either but I I'd have a hard
time voting against a 12 and a half
percent tax at wholesale two one two
point five
at wholesale
and production and we can get this done
okay let's see I'll just go around again
go collectorize representatively
I appreciate people's willingness to
discuss a bill that we all want to see
move forward so that feels like a
positive development
um
another thought is I think we're also
concerned about the barriers to this
industry and the startup costs and I'm
wondering if
um there might be room
to discuss I believe it's New Mexico
has a tax I believe it's on the
wholesale it may be on the retail but
when they passed legalization they set
the tax to increase
I think starting in the year 2025 to
increase by one percent per year
for you know x amount of years not for
it to go infinitely up but
since we know it is expensive to get
into this market and it's difficult we
want to keep those barriers low if we
started at a 12.5 percent at the
wholesale and we're concerned that that
might not cover a cost we could Inc you
know build in and increase over the
following three years that would be a
mechanism we could discuss in the
interest of time is again we could keep
going around and around on this and I
feel like we've had a couple of
statements made that may be able to get
us somewhere
let's do a straw poll on
using the wholesale rate as defined by
the spillsbury
Amendment
at 12 and a half percent
how many people can vote for that and
incorporate this paragraph five which
demands the commission come back to us
and revisit this issue how many people
could support those two things
I'm sorry nope I'm sorry representative
janigan go ahead sorry hold on
representative yeah I'd like to make one
statement um
I can support representative doucet's
12.5 and here's something based on what
representative Ames said about
and I agree with him that when this bill
first came to us let's remember it was
passed on the house floor
it was 15 however it was formally
a cultivator tax now that it's a
cultivator
and a producer tax 12 and a half makes
sense so I think if you if you were okay
with 15 before
even if you're not think about the house
voting for this 12 and a half percent
makes sense since we have broadened this
thank you
okay
sorry let's just see where we are and
then we can keep going all of those in
favor of that motion I just made please
raise your hand so we can see where
we're at
all those opposed
hopefully we'll get to the same
four five six seven
minutes
okay so that's the best consensus we've
had in a while representative uh it's
not Heinz I keep looking at the wrong
thing representative
uh thank you madam chair as a co-sponsor
of the bill and a town that said with 65
that we want this and and town
counselors that send a full
um thing we did look at the issue of
taxing at this level early on so this
bill gives us a unique opportunity
unlike all the other states that have
say 1.5 billion dollars in sale in
Massachusetts where they still have a
black market by having a lower rate we
have the opportunity to actually price
out the black market I think the idea of
having the commission revisit this makes
sense but we may want to have them
revisit it once it's been on the market
for a year because if we have sales that
suggest that we are actually eliminating
the black market we may have done
something unique in this country that
should be recognized so that would just
be my one question as to whether we
would want them to have a report after
2024 or if they can do it's an ongoing
basis to see if we've actually
eliminated the black market
thank you representative Olney
yes what I didn't get allowed to say
before on I apologize about that
wholesale uh tax on cigarettes is about
68 percent
and it is totally uh ignored by the
people buying the cigarettes because
it's just a stamp and they don't can't
read the stamp anyway
um and it's the lowest
in the nation I believe and it's the
lowest
um
certainly the lowest in our region and
we provide the cigarettes for a large
number of people from Massachusetts and
Vermont and Maine and Connecticut and
sometimes New York if the price of gas
isn't too high
so on wholesale is a whole different
animal
than retail
and on I would like to see it at
wholesale but I think that we should
have at least been at 15 percent and
probably 25 percent okay would be my
bottom estimate okay we just took a vote
though so now we have two things we have
a majority vote on so we got to keep
moving chair I've had my mic on for a
long time
go ahead
so in this last round of discussion I
just want to say that there's two things
we have not the the wholesale level
proposal does not deal with the fact
that we know that um the existing some
at least some of the existing facilities
we have now with for therapeutic
cannabis cannabis are integrated
companies and they want to
do all levels of the production and so
we don't have any way to determine what
the wholesale value of the the the of
the cultivated product we have no way to
determine what that is so how are we
going to tax that
and
the other thing that I want to point out
is that it that this bill at the very
beginning under purpose and findings
begins with that the purpose of this is
allowing num first item allowing law
enforcement to focus on violent and
property crimes
second
priority
reason for this bill is generating
revenue for Education prevention
treatment and Recovery it is absolutely
our job to make sure that there is money
going to be available for those things
so we know right off the bat that
after we get pay for pay off the
development cost at The Liquor
Commission the ongoing costs have been
estimated at four and a half million a
year we need to be able to raise a
reasonable amount of money to address
these other issues
and I don't think taxing at the
wholesale level is going to get us there
it I would say that when I look at the
spot market price of wholesale
outdoor cannabis
this week on the Cannabis benchmarks
that taxing at 15 percent Which is
higher than than you've been talking
about on an ounce of cannabis is going
to generate four dollars and fifty cents
of Revenue
and that's you're going to have to sell
a heck of a lot of cannabis
to get a reasonable amount of money to
pay off over 4 million a year plus help
education and treatment programs and the
police and reimburse the police for the
additional enforcement that they'll have
to do so that's what I have to say
representative Ames
yeah I appreciate that last point about
the
reality that some some uh sellers of
cannabis or some that are in the chain
of from gross growing cannabis to its
final sale
will be integrated operations and I did
have I'd lost track of this I did have a
paragraph that would go into this tax
imposed section section
um that uh would read as follows the
commission may determine the selling or
transfer price of the Cannabis or
cannabis products when the seller and
purchaser are affiliated persons or
entities and when the sale or transfer
of the Cannabis or cannabis product is
not in arm's length the transaction so
it makes explicit that one of the jobs
of the commission is to price the uh
point that cannabis moves
uh from
the cultivator to a retailer or from the
manufacturer to a retailer and makes
that clear that that that's the pricing
that we're looking for and it's going to
be taxed
well representative spoolsburg
uh thank you representative Ames I'm
just listening to that at first blush it
sounds like a constructive Edition that
helps to clarify what we've really been
saying
I would want to look at it more closely
with you for example
um
to determine
is subject to a competing interpretation
sometimes it's to determine is like to
discover in other times to determine is
to set we don't want in any way suggest
that the commission is going to set uh
the prices so how about ascertain for
example ascertain would be fine and I
think then we could go along with that
if we Embrace that idea if we embrace
section five of the fellows Amendment
um
I think we've really clarified what
we've been discussing the ambiguous
parts of what we've been discussing and
we keep the uh the rate we we broadcast
that we expect that the rate can be
fluid in coming years
so let's just settle on a figure today
as pragmatists we've narrowed the range
12 and a half give or take uh
won't it be a great thing given the kind
of resounding majority vote we had last
month if this committee can come out
virtually unanimous
so let's just do it if I may just
representative
um
I take your point and uh it may be okay
to leave it as is this language that I
read to you is straight out of the
Illinois statute which has a tax on the
co at the cultivator level and that's
why they felt they needed
language like this I suspect our Liquor
Commission would welcome tax language
like this
so I would encourage it I guess while
I've got the mic I might as well respond
to uh two two a suggestion a proposal
and a request
friend here
and that is the proposal was
that the tax rate would be 12.5 percent
on the
um on on the proposal that I had made
instead of 15 and
um
and you had asked me to come up with
something so I would suggest 13 percent
and that's to you know just get it out
there
it's
I think we might want to take another
straw vote just to see where we're at
um because again we could discuss this
all day and I apologize I don't I just
don't know when we would ever stop
discussing this so right now we have
another revised proposal we already had
passed with the majority 13 to 7 a 12.5
percent
could we get more people if we went to
13 and Incorporated some of these
technical improvements that we've just
discussed so that is the question on the
table now
how many people would support 13 percent
making sure the commission comes back to
us with information giving them some
more technical clarifications how many
people could support that keeping it at
the wholesale level
as described by the spillsburg amendment
how many people could support 13 percent
do we get any votes do we add any people
to that no we lost
we lost point of order
how many people is that
so we didn't get make any progress with
that representative homie Madam chair on
just this is just procedural uh it's 110
I have two amendments one of which is
critical to this thing namely changing
the Appropriations for the Liquor
Commission so that they can start to
work uh and the other of which is on has
a lot of cleaning up of Errata that was
not found so far and is except that they
didn't put some of my cleanup into into
the amendment that they did I have the
original language which I'd need to go
back to them for
um and
on and
on fixing the
the nomenclature and the funding of the
treatment facilities the way they had on
expected to be in the bill as it came
out
uh
from the Commerce Committee at the last
minute
with on some major drafting issues let's
see
and also fixing the language of the
Liquor Commission which has major
drafting errors at this point because if
they want to keep
liquor separate from Cannabis this bill
ain't going to do it
point of order
I know you have a plan
um right now we're at 13 7.
those numbers are almost identical to
our constituents vote and the House vote
I mean it's about two-thirds one-thirds
yeah to me my my sense of you know we
should move on because now we have
enough of a majority on two things two
two major chunks and now we'd move on to
some other things although it sounds
like representative Alma you need to go
back to OLS to get that fixed before you
can vote on it is that correct or
I asked them to do they forgot they
forgot a small part of it so here's a
Here's a thought we could uh break now
so you guys can get some lunch and then
I know OLS is going to have to do some
work here and we're going to have to
come back right it sounds like we've got
a lot we've got a lot of Corrections it
sounds like representative Ames
representative spilsbury need to get
together and get their language together
fine tune what we've already agreed on
what the majority agreed on and put that
into one Amendment
that would give you time to get your
fixes done at OLS and then maybe we come
back at two ish does that sound close
and can they do that I know I don't know
that's a good question representative
maybe tomorrow I just they got it very
they got my stuff very fast this morning
because they didn't look at it until
this morning and I haven't had a chance
to look completely at what they may have
missed or not I apologize I saw a bunch
of hands I don't know representative
Doucette but it's all are there any
other amendments to be offered to this
piece yes representative Almy has
several but oh there's more yes
right
do we want to discuss that now or after
or
yeah well so we have an opportunity to
take a little break now while people
start we're fine-tuning their amendments
that we know we need to be fine-tuned
um or we can keep going it's up to you I
think we should do his Amendment now
because he's got it ready okay yeah
representative send it around
and again I'm so glad we didn't start
this the year with this bill in a way
because this is tough and I thank you
for your hard work would have been nice
to have a month and a half to work on it
so this starts on page 12.
of of the original bill
I did yes I sent them around yeah
all right
page 12.
yeah
actually it's on the bottom of page 11
is where this starts but the meat of it
is on page 12.
so I'm hoping this uh this isn't a
dramatic this is this isn't huge
um if you look on page 12 uh when they
talk about dual use
certificates so facilities that are
therapeutic and also want to get into
retail sales
um this is the only section that I could
find where defines a specific price for
a license or an application fee if you
look on page seven it gives guidelines
for application fees for other for the
retail facilities or other facilities
but this where this is it specifically
defines that where it says the
commission shall Levy a ten thousand
dollar application fee for a dual yield
certificate and if approved it will
continue to it will charge a ninety
thousand dollar licensing fee with no
expiration date so this amendment just
eliminates that uh ten thousand dollar
application fee it eliminates the ninety
thousand dollar license fee and it
eliminates the uh
you know indefinite
expiration date for that so the the
commission is empowered on page seven
um lines 23 through uh 2032 to actually
develop fees so we're just eliminating
this uh this very prescriptive fee for
for a couple reasons one because I think
it's high and I think these facilities
are probably well adapted and um
accustomed to to doing this business uh
so to add a hundred thousand dollars on
top of that I don't think is is
necessarily right the other thing that I
I think is problematic with defining
this is when the commission starts
looking at other fees and other
licensing application fees and Licensing
fees they're going to look to well
there's a conflict but first of all
they're going to look to this as what's
the standard fee that we have and a
hundred thousand dollars is could be
their their Baseline
um uh as they look to develop a
comparison however the problem that the
conflict arises in page seven line 30 it
says the non-refundable portion
application fee shall not exceed a
thousand dollars adjusted for inflation
which having done fees for regulated
Industries that's more in line with
reality than a ten thousand dollar
application fee uh and certainly a
ninety thousand dollar license fee is is
out of line so that's the amendment
that's what the amendment does and um
that's about it
okay we're I'm not sure who was first
representative almi go ahead and then
representative Ames thank you
this on
these I was a little shocked by this too
but I'm not we no longer have the Liquor
Commission here we no longer have the on
the gentleman who came here to talk
three times now I think from on the the
health HHS group that is running these
alternative oh oh that's you
so maybe can can you ask him to talk
about this I believe that this is what
you call an Enterprise fee which is
something that is illegal and less
regulated
uh and it's the kind of fees that the
casino bills always had before you
turned it into a charitable Enterprise
uh
so um
um maybe you can you talk about the
these these levels that are in here
yeah come on up and recognize if you
could just introduce yourself and just
help us just specifically on these
application and Licensing fees that
we're entertaining removing yes thank
you madam chair my name is Michael Holt
I am the administrator for the
Department of Health and Human Services
Division of Public Health Services
therapeutic cannabis program
um so these these this dual use fee has
a bit of a history
um my understanding is that this hundred
thousand dollar combined application
license uh certificate fee was to be
directed to a social Equity Fund
um in the original legislation that that
uh that was removed when the bill was
introduced
um but those fees remained in the bill
and they were redirected basically to
the the Cannabis uh Commission Now
change to the Liquor Commission the
liquor and cannabis commission and so
it's unclear to me if that up to seven
hundred thousand dollars
um would was needed for the Liquor
Commission to run the program
um they've not testified on that so I'm
assuming that that was not part of their
their fiscal note so we have this this
bucket of money hundred hundred thousand
dollars per dispensary location of which
there are currently seven in the state
that could
pay into pay this fee to begin serving
adult use patients they've got the
cultivation facilities built out they've
got the retail facilities uh built out
many states have done this before
um it is a way to uh get to Market
sooner than
um than than waiting for the entire
adult use Market to get built out and so
this originally served two purposes one
to feed a social Equity Fund and two uh
to increase time to Market to get adult
use sales uh moving and so
this is uh so this is my this is my
pitch I don't know whether or not this
is an Enterprise tax or is illegal
representative homie I can't speak to
that piece
um but the issue that the Department of
Health and Human Services has is that
there is no appropriation
for a preliminary public education
campaign about the risks of cannabis use
in various populations there is a
requirement for the Department to uh to
to conduct that public education
campaign but it is funded
by the bill after
through Revenue right so there's there's
there that we have the responsibility of
conducting public education campaigns
about the risk of cannabis use but
there's no money to do that until
Revenue starts coming in and the the x
million dollars
um is paid back by The Liquor Commission
so
um this is a this is an issue that is
both policy and Financial in that
um there's we feel the need believe the
need for preliminary funds to fund a
public education campaign I believe uh
representative Almy has um has an
amendment in her in her stack that would
fund that preliminarily
um one other idea was in order to fund
it properly is that those fees
regardless of whether they are too high
or or not that's a different issue could
be redirected to HHS for that fund so in
place of removing the fee entirely the
atcs could be a source of funds
supplementary funds you know to HHS for
performing that function and that was an
idea that I uh that we had brought up uh
to representative Almy for consideration
um and presentation to this body
so how's that great thank you it was
very helpful to have your perspective of
course I'm wondering it from a business
perspective a hundred thousand dollars
seems like a lot of money would that be
a huge barrier but that's all just I
will say that there is at least one
member of uh representative from the
atcs here as well his name is Matt Simon
um he he may have an opinion on the
amount of the money but again that was
some that that amount was signed off on
before the bill was introduced to be
dedicated to uh essentially a social
Equity Fund uh to build training
opportunities for you know farmers and
for disadvantaged
um uh entities to enter the Cannabis uh
Market
um that if they had been
disproportionately uh impacted by the
War on Drugs thank you that's all gone
from it but the fee remains okay so
thank you very much
um all right so we have uh this
amendment before us
representatively
I just had a question I think the the
point race is very valid I think we need
to stop and discuss this it sounds like
way too much money to me
um
just a clarification and if I'm just in
error please help me
um is the same amount
charged to for every retail license that
is available because my impression was
that this is just for them
no actually if you look on page seven
um it charges the and it is it's
specifically called out in the bill dual
use certificates so it we just heard
it's taking seven individuals seven
entities in in
making them fund uh whatever they had a
fund now they're not even we don't even
know where the money's going around
right but no uh so if you look at page
seven
um and this is where it gets interesting
page seven line 28 and 30 it says the
commission shall the shall establish
fees uh that the non-refundable portion
of the application fees shall not exceed
one thousand dollars for the regular
retail you know Mom and Pops but they're
10 times that for for these dual use
so it sounds like the story behind it is
you know something was pulled out and
maybe this just needs to be cleaned up
and done the same
represent only
two things one on
my I have two amendments one amendment
was from uh DHHS with some
additions that had nothing to do with
the amendment uh erotic Corrections on
on but the the other one is the
Appropriations one and that one can
function with with or without this 700
000 coming in it just takes longer to
pay off the debt if if it isn't there
but to the other thing is could we ask
Mr Simon to tell us what they know about
this issue
if anything
sure I'll just
happy to do that thank you for being
here of course this is not a public
hearing so we just we can't get too
crazy with this but thank you very much
for being here
my pleasure very briefly Matt Simon
Prime ATC and I did testify to this so I
think it's just a reminder I agree with
the way Mr Holt characterized this we
agreed to the Dual use fees during the
drafting process with the understanding
that those funds would be going towards
a cannabis Business Development Fund and
a Justice reinvestment fund both of
which we thought were very good causes
we want to try to help create a cannabis
Marketplace that New Hampshire can
really be proud of and it was in that
spirit that we agreed to these fees
now that those fees are gone I asked are
these fees still appropriate should they
be reduced or eliminated for example the
fee for an integrated license in Vermont
which is pretty similar to what we're
talking about here is fifty thousand
dollars which is half of that so that's
just one one data point but
I'd be happy to answer any other
questions if you have them but don't
want to take up your time
thank you very much we really appreciate
that so we have an amendment before us
um
I just want to get a sense from people
representative fellows would you have
something so if
with the elimination of those lines in
here does it still allow the Cannabis
licorice liquor cannabis commission to
assess some kind of fee
yes representative Rosewood if you could
point that out but I believe it's in the
original Bill uh page seven they kind of
goes through all that to come up with a
reasonable
fee
which is how things are normally done uh
especially a new emerging business like
this what what is normal what is
appropriate I'm not sure any of us
really know
other than comparing to other states I
guess and I I mean I I don't know
because this is new in New Hampshire
um having come from the background of a
regular regulated business and having a
day job that does licensing for
regulated businesses I mean you know
New Hampshire is top of the list for
fees uh but even that where one of the
one of the ones it's like two thousand
dollars for a two-year license uh 500
for various fees
um you know uh like I said I work around
the country and I think you know two to
three thousand dollars is the most we've
ever seen for dealing in narcotics
represent homie
yes I'd just like to add that I believe
these numbers for the Enterprise came
out of the discussion about having one
major Casino in Salem
and on that
that it for each of the Cannabis
cultivation facilities and dual use
facilities to to have to come up with a
hundred thousand dollars does seem
pretty much out of line
with one major in the whole state
Casino
Arizona
um
thank you I was wondering now that we
have all of the I think amendments on
the table and we're not going to be
completely blindsided by any new
information if it might be okay if we
take lunch and we can all kind of
percolate
um
just a request thank you
that's a great suggestion so uh so
basically it's 1 30 so I'm going to open
the exact session and then I'm going to
recess the exact session until what time
do you think 2 30 should we shoot for
that 2 30
well recess to 230 so
you should have your amendments cleaned
up and ready to go by then if you
possibly can
okay
well we we got to see yours but you told
us it was wrong so we need the right
version so if you can get the right
version
can you put on your mic so we can just
real quick guys can you focus on what
representative Almy has to say real
quick before you head out yeah they
um one of them was a track changes with
red
on it and it says Amendment one change
of Appropriations doesn't even say it's
me uh and the other one which is from
the liquor uh for the uh
mostly for HHS is four pages on
double-sided two pages stapled together
with every single change in
in the um original bill as amended that
we've been dealing with
on and a little bit of it intersects
with representative but nothing that
objects to represent rochewitz
okay so everyone make sure you look at
those and come back at 2 30. it's a lot
easier to look at because the ones that
that they gave me are repealing and
reenacting different language which
means that you can't even see the
changes
I just wanted to represent only could uh
combine that all into one Amendment
uh
I could do that but it's two totally
different issues
the Appropriations is is pretty quick to
understand and it's about the
Appropriations whereas the other one
well I did include the Errata in here
but so that's right so I have another
trying to separate take take the
Cannabis commission out of things is
somebody doing an amendment on
the tax imposed which is on page 22 and
has the 15 percent uh cultivation taxes
my understanding is that representative
spilsbury was going to his Amendment
changing that and work with
representative Ames on some of the
additional language and put that onto
one so it's easier to to put
representative Ames language that's
did you want to rewrite this or keep it
right like that
oh okay
so so as the essence paragraph five will
be incorporated
as well as the other uh that
representative Ames read to us
excellent I know you guys are probably
starving thank you so much and I know
this is really tough but I really
appreciate it thank you
foreign
thank you
okay
so we are not an exec session We are
continuing a work session
I think because do we have an amendment
from representative almi
there was only
out on
and she's doing that and she said she'd
try to get it over but I don't have high
hopes that she'll get it over quickly
okay well why don't you do you have two
different things here right so why don't
you bring up one at a time I mean the
the
joke like this
this compare them at lunch time with
what what she put down and she said oh
yeah I guess I left that paragraph out
it was the paragraph that established
the uh the HHS fund
which is kind of important if you're
sending the money from somewhere else to
that fund but you're using a different
name than the fund has
okay uh represent I understand
representative Almy and I am fully
sympathetic but I need a number to put
on this sheet for an amendment so I kind
of have to wait for them to come back oh
dear yeah
because she was just going to actually
um maybe just send that one page
I guess she can't can she
well okay Innis could you just summarize
what this does yes
on
most of this
um well there are two of these
and the way she did this amendment
this one is necessary because she if
this one passed because she wiped out
the Appropriations in this one
I don't know why but she she just
thought that that that it wasn't needed
since the other one was doing it
a lot of them are new
this year I've noticed
okay so so what you're trying to do is
there's already a cannabis fund
established in the original Bill and
you're just trying to send some of that
money to something specific is that what
you're trying to do no yeah the the
amendment no actually not quite because
it's not as easy as that but um the one
that is
um
track changes the one that you're
looking at Amendment one that doesn't
need any changes at this point
um
but what it does
is
instead of
them asking for the funding that we are
now going to get rid of anyway if we
vote for representative wrote Sports
Amendment which I agree with
also on
except for that
on
which is in here
with
they are trying to Corral back that 700
000 to use
in here and I left it in there because
I didn't know yet whether this one could
pass
but
and those and I've identified those
sections so that we can take them out if
representative wrote for its bill on
Amendment passes
um
the amendment one change of
Appropriations
on does
uh two main things
it puts
on 15 million
in a total of 15 million into
The Liquor Commission for purposes of
startup of this whole program they gave
us a list of their of the expenses that
and how they were calculating them last
time it's 7 million in the first year
and 8 million in the second it's a lot
different from what this bill came to us
with because at that point they had not
yet gone to try to find out how much
how much software they were going to
need and how much it was going to cost
and they do seem to have
enough of a handle on that
that
I don't see getting in their way about
getting them what they need in order to
do this program
um they have three separate
software packages that they need one of
them being seed seed to brownie
uh tracking these things and
um two of them having to do I think one
with with
um Workforce and the other one with
revenues with uh finances
on
but I need to refresh my memory on that
one
but
um they said these are very specific to
cannabis
they told us all that they are
um
on
there are very few vendors that make
them they don't expect very many bids
and that this that they think that
they're going to need about four million
dollars just for those
uh just for those software packages and
that they're going to need it I
think they said need need the whole
fourth million dollars again the second
year as the package gets worked into the
New Hampshire context
and
on when we did dra I think we spent
5 million the first
to first to get data processing fixed
and then it was six million more
recently to develop the analytic
capacity that we now
enjoy with dra
they are expensive and
so
I was doing this with the idea that if
we only give them 2 million they can't
do anything
so
that the 2 million is approximately what
they think they're going to need
um
need for the staff
Ing and they'll need more of it the
second year than the first because
they'll be getting ready for the
continuing project which they estimated
to us is going to cost about four
million two I think uh
on each each year of operation
and they do have to
do testing and on all those little Farms
people are going to be allowed to set up
as well as the big big outfits
or oversee the testing at any rate make
sure that go test the testers
um they're going to have to be going to
all the retail establishments and all of
the
wholesale
establishments on a fairly regular basis
in the wholesale establishments
so uh
they may be padding that some
and it'd be something that we could push
back on later
but I was just taking
what they came up with
as as the idea the 4.2 does not show up
in here because under the bill
once they are actually selling stuff
some stuff and getting Revenue in
from licenses they're going to have to
apply
they they will take the 4.2 out of that
which leaves it pretty low the first
first year if they took all of it but
probably they'd stretch it out over a
couple of years
um well they're going to have to stretch
out the 15 million over a couple years
at least
so
um
that's what what that part of it does
the second and it's in two parts because
I was trying to originally in finance
and they always have the Appropriations
at the end
even if they're also somewhere in the
middle
so um
the second on the the last appropriation
on in that first section is the
substance use prevention and Recovery
Fund from HHS
on which
wants
money up front before we start getting
money in for public education campaign
before the sales start
so that people will know who's supposed
who
who should avoid trying to to use
marijuana at all because it might be bad
for the illnesses they've got or
genetics that they've got and
um
and um
how much
on
how much on is a high dose of marijuana
versus a low dose of marijuana so that
you don't get people experimenting that
have never tried marijuana before at the
highest level and just going off the
edge
which happened in Colorado
at the beginning
so um
they wanted the seven hundred thousand
dollars I put it down at five hundred
thousand dollars they seem to be okay
with that
or at least Hope was okay with that he
sent me an email this morning
when he got back to work
so the second part of at section 33
amendments is just saying okay the 15
million seven million is in the first
year of the biennium and 8 million is in
the second year of the biennium
and
and I think
and and that the 500
000 is for the buying
now all of that has attached to it
um
in
in the first part in 3 3 18 21.
on
the the sum is appropriated to the
Cannabis commission for for x and said
Son shall be a charge against the fund
which means that when they start getting
in profits part of the profits has to go
back until they finish paying off the 15
million and the 500 000.
from the different the two different
funds
so that that's the Appropriations one
okay so that's one potential amendment
that you have now at OLS
well that Amendment
is probably the way it has to be uh from
OLS and oh that one
that one is here okay okay so let's pass
that out and then uh we'll ask
representative all me any clarifying
questions we have and then do a straw
poll on that yeah can you clarify what's
being passed around is it part one or
part two it's uh
it's the Appropriations part one
yes it is except that
when they did the drafting I don't know
how they decide sometimes we're just
going to amend sections three and four
of of
this part of the bill
and when they decide okay we're
rewriting the whole thing they rewrote
the whole I did not I asked just to
change those sections they re rewrote
the whole bill which means that the
pre-spilsbury
uh
model for how the the distribution goes
is in there intact so that has to come
out if this amendment and that Amendment
are passed
thanks
Madam chair that would happen if we
passed the Omni Amendment first and then
the uh and later the uh well the
roachford amendment and then thirdly the
spillsbury amendment that this Pillsbury
member wind up lasting right maybe I'll
Blended together
this one did not amend the Dual use
this is just the Cannabis fund but
anything else that did the Cannabis fund
it's going to have to
we're going to have to know the order in
which these were were done in order to
know what comes out and what stays in
that's the clerk's job that's the
clerk's job but also on
we need to make really careful this
comes out outright and
okay so where where is the appropriation
for like even the 500 000 in here I
don't even see that I could be blind
on it's page one and section um line 16
it starts
are you looking at 12 23
yeah uh no you aren't no I'm looking at
12 24. yeah
oh did I pass out the wrong one oh shoot
here
yeah 1224 is is more complicated
wait a minute
no no
did I
um
well this here's 12 23.
I guess a few more
I do apologize
thank you yeah
12 24 is the one that has a paragraph
missing
no no
because she might only send back the one
page
okay well there's obviously several
different sections to this but in in a
nutshell we are dramatically increasing
the amount of money we're putting aside
under this bill which is pretty big and
I did miss a lot of the work sessions so
I I didn't hear what the commission
liquor said about this
um was this something they asked for of
the committee they gave us a sheet with
all their expenses and they said said we
need this in order to proceed
um I'm not sure where my copy of the
sheet is
the police representative help us
thank you madam chair So based on the
notes that I took
um at the last committee meeting
the commission said in the first year
they would need seven million dollars
and 5 million of that was for the
systems that they were gonna what's that
yeah five million uh for the systems
that they're going to be putting in
place uh before this the um the other
two million was for a combination of
Office Space
uh Construction office furniture cars
and payroll
right salaries and benefits so that that
was 2 million and then 5 million again
for the system the second year
they said they would um
they would need eight million oh and um
actually I don't have much more than
that so the second year they wanted
eight million presumably you know the
the
I'm guessing that you know when I look
at the jump to the third year they
needed 4.2 million they're fully staffed
and they need to maintain the systems so
my guess is part of that eight million
do you have it here yeah this is
consultant cost
well three so in the second year three
million is
um office costs startup costs and five
million oh I see so the licensing the
system was 5 million in the first year
as I said
another 5 million in the second year
um probably because of implementation
and Consulting costs and then the third
year was just was just
um a million
um for ongoing system maintenance
so so to recap first year they said
seven million second year eight million
third year four point two million
so does this amendment address what was
said as yes okay
so we're again we're in a work session
there's no more clarifying questions
how many people
support Amendment
1223 h
how many are posts
anybody opposed I only have 16 people
here now
looks like we're all here at the moment
some people apparently didn't vote
okay so the strong majority of people
are okay with this because you guys
heard the Liquor Commission wanted it so
okay there we go okay second one with
the exception of
sections uh
six Romans six
of section Romans 6 which is the part
that this Pillsbury Amendment so this
will be redrafted so that it doesn't
trip over and undo arama okay so can you
just make notes on your copy on what
really needs to change there so uh we'll
have to think about this maybe in the
order of operations when we go to exact
session we do this first we do the
roachford amendment next
and then we do the spillsbury amendment
Okay so good now we'll go back to I
would ask we do it the other way around
let's get the foundation of all of the
broad consensus we had
and then
modify that okay uh is that okay what
does it matter what order we take up the
Amendments here
gotcha
class
class places
so
all of the amendments
so that they can be combined into one
maybe a magnet that is
good so we're we're going to end up with
the same result
um because OLS is restating all of
section 7 which runs page three to 22
inclusive so one supersedes the other oh
whichever order you do it
so whichever order we do it we've got a
problem that we got rid of something
that we just voted for
effectively this amendment I think needs
to be trimmed
ideally yeah okay
so you could go back to OLS and trim
this back
yeah what
what I was hoping we could do is that
two of us at least could go to OLS
together
uh and make sure that they take the
parts that we want and not the parts we
don't want yep
would that work
we could come up with one Amendment
ideally can come up with one amendment
that you all agree to because we both
guess that okay well let's keep moving
on and we can maybe Quicken this up a
little bit just to see what amendments
do we have and then we go to maybe two
of you go to OLS and say this is what we
want but and tell them where the fixes
are and when we put it together so we
end up with one committee Amendment but
at least we'll have votes on the
individual amendments here
well no should we have to do that first
but that we can't do the final vote yeah
yeah okay so we have a stravo con
conceptually we agree with that
representative lippley
um I don't think we ever voted on
representative Rose Schertz okay I just
want to make sure we're that's the
problem
so well we can do that now if that would
help because we all know what that is
representative on me if we could I'd
just like to
correct the parts that need to come out
are 6B
because I had if we take out all of six
we've taken out the appropriation for
safety for data collection
but then f everything after that
in that section is is replaced by this
buildsbury amendment
or did the spilsbury amendment have the
hundred
million 100
000 in it
yeah okay yeah
okay so let's yeah represent over
thank you
I on page two of the amendment here it
says eighty percent shall be dispersed
to the education trust fund that's what
I was just talking about that's the
spilsbury amendment I mean that is not
the spillsbury amendment that's what
they're immense he's a man they're
amending thank you sorry yeah so where
yeah so that exact part is going to have
to come out so we're doing straw votes
on four or five different things once we
think we've got the consensus of the
majority then representative almi and
representative spilsbury will go to OLS
merge these together take out the
conflicting language
and come back to us for a final fabulous
vote
that's going to be today okay so now
we're going back let's look at
representative rochford's Amendment so
we can just see if we have a straw vote
on that because that if we don't take
that up then that changes things too
yeah right
everyone remember so that's uh Amendment
that was the one we did right before the
lunch break which has to do with
removing those huge upfront
application fees and licenses is that
correct
Madam chair can you remind us
um where we were when we took lunch I
believe we had agreed on a
did we say 13.5 uh no so on a different
Amendment we had a 13-7 vote on a 12.5
on the thank you wholesale that's what I
was looking for thank you okay
okay so everyone got The Roaster
amendment in front of them
can I ask a question yes
um so I agree with the thought behind
this and I think one of the things that
we've heard is important is to lower the
barriers right upstart startup barriers
and this is very clearly like let's put
this up front before you can even do
anything so I would agree with taking it
out
um my only concern being that you know
that changes the numbers would we would
we be willing to discuss
kind of evening out the three different
sets of numbers that we've discussed by
revisiting the 12.5 I guess is my
question
I think that's addressed with
Representatives almi's Amendment if I
got that right would that appropriate
that initial appropriation
um I believe that's what we talked about
with the gentleman from HHS prior to
lunch
um
five hundred thousand yes five hundred
thousand yes so uh
eliminating the the fees
is the the the the the makeup is in that
amendment that she has proposed where we
get the 500 000 appropriation can can I
say this out loud so I make sure I'm
getting it right so my understanding was
your amendment was
we were taking out
New Hampshire would not receive seven
hundred thousand dollars
um and the amendment that representative
almi is proposing is actually New
Hampshire is spending five hundred
thousand dollars to educate folks so
that is a net 1.2 million dollars
of less Revenue than we had when we
voted on the 12.5 percent I just was
wondering if we could revisit and maybe
do some corrections
to because I I think it's more fair if
we don't have the 700 000 and you
distribute that
um across the businesses that are
actually making money because the
hundred thousand is charged before
they've made any money at all
representative almond
yes on
the 500 000 that they get for the
biennium
and they'll spend it bit by bit rather
than having it all locked up I think at
one time on is uh has to be paid back
uh through what they get in later years
from the marijuana uh Commission
and what they get back at a later time
I guess at this point isn't going to be
very much money
since
on but they're they're two issues with
that one that the other one is in the
timing in this which
I need to talk about also but
um
they're
what they're going to be getting back
from this is basically
just I think someone else remind me if
I'm wrong on that on all they get back
is five percent of the profits
that are left after whose they is it HHS
yes HHS
uh it which is controlling the fund that
does the education
my question was I guess about the this
Revenue right if if the state is giving
money to DHHS that money has to come
from somewhere yes
um and if we're not charging seven
hundred thousand dollars in licensing
fees that's less Revenue that we're
getting so I was just wondering if if we
could think about the overall cost of
the bill yeah well that
that is at least theoretically if we've
got a way of giving them
money after the like the licensing and
the purchases start on they are supposed
to be paying that back it is carried uh
the appropriation to a fund there are a
lot a number of funds that go into the
red at different times of the year
dedicated funds and that money is
carried as a negative number by the
treasury for that fund and when the fund
gets enough
money above their operation costs that
could pay back that money it's applied
to the negative
so that they eventually come back to a
positive you hope right but shouldn't
that money that's going out shouldn't
that money be repaid by a tax on
cannabis not from their General
appropriation
they don't have a general appropriation
for this
okay so
we have a vote before us and but I will
let's just remind the group that we did
a straw vote on going from 12.5 percent
to 13 and there was no appetite for that
it did not pass so I don't I think that
would be unrealistic
and I hear you but I just I'm not sure
we should go backwards I think it may be
appropriate to do a straw vote on this
amendment understanding that that
doesn't seem to be a lot of bipartisan
appetite to change from the 12.5 percent
okay
so well
well yes representative homie yes just
just basically one thing on the this
doesn't mean that they're not going to
the the businesses that are in this are
aren't going to pay anything
what this means is that the Liquor
Commission is going to establish a
reasonable
license fee
and we don't know what that is and the
other point I would make is we're going
to make more money out of this so we
think I mean people have been very
pessimistic I think there'll be enough
revenues to cover all this
well
okay so let's do a straw vote there is
one other thing that is brought into
question by this the in in my second
amendment that we haven't discussed yet
on they changed the 18 months to a year
uh
at without this at 18 months after the
effective date of this chapter
The Liquor Commission is going to be
wrapping up is going to oh it's just
going to be starting doing rules we need
them to be in sync that both the Dual
use and the regular cannabis
organizations are getting their rules at
the same time and can get their licenses
at the same time and go forward
because otherwise we're we're
prejudicing against the Dual use groups
that all want to also do adult cannabis
I think all of them do
okay all right so we're looking at yes
18 months is okay we'll do that next
um let's talk about 1217 that's the
rochefort amendment
let's understand what it is all those in
favor of that Amendment raise your hand
s
[Music]
ome
I think it's 20. okay all right so this
broad support for that thank the
goodness okay all right so we have a
couple things now let's go to
representative almies in the Second
Amendment and then we will then go back
to the spillsbury amendment and then
hopefully we can merge them all together
okay again these are straw votes uh can
you what oh
so
keeping everything okay
so this one
this was the one that we've just
done
I think no it isn't
right
okay so yeah
this is 2 12 28.
and I don't have a copy yet I gave you
more
and the previous version of it
you all should
tear up or something so we don't get
confused on
what no I'm asking 12 23.
I think no wait a minute
yeah okay
we are doing 12 23.
uh
there's not enough room in this place
for all these papers
no no 12
no 12 23
is the one that we're replacing
we just voted 20
20. yes
right it's replacing 12.4
yeah yeah right now we're we're talking
about 12 replacing 12 24.
and the only thing that this does
different
from
from 1224
is that
oh I forgot to take out the Liquor
Commission but anyway
um
certificates
ten percent
oh yeah it's on page three line 34 we
start the paragraph that they forgot to
put in
which is Substance Abuse Prevention and
Recovery Fund established
which it's
we needed that one in there still
and it also changed its name to what
they're using
um
but I have a couple of other things to
say
say about this I asked them to do two
things
um and if you look
at
the yellow highlighted version
of this
you can see
what
what I'm talking about
a lot better than you can yeah
my copy had
disappeared here
ah thank you sharp eyes
um
I had separated these out
by using a different type font Ariel 12
for for what I was sticking in to what
the
the HHS group wanted from this
there are it most a lot of it is just
they corrected the
um
the number of the RSA that that relates
to the Cannabis fund and to the
substance use prevention and Recovery
Fund uh because they had the numbers
wrong because they kept the numbers from
from the previous uh bill
from the original bill that came to the
house
they've changed all the Substance Abuse
Prevention recovery funds to substance
use
which they prefer
we're using
um
and they've taken out the word trust
from trust fund where it appears in two
places uh in there because it the trust
fund was in the first version of the
bill and wasn't in the one that left
Commerce
yes go ahead I have a problem with the
word use it isn't use it abuse
is she named it
yeah I don't care what they named it we
name it
all right we have a bunch of wait hands
waving over in this direction can we yes
go ahead please representative
I guess I'm wanting to make the same
point from a different angle
um if that's true maybe we should go
throughout the statutes and change
from use to abuse because we're taking
something which has been an illegal
activity and we're making it legal we're
not setting up the programs to treat
what we are legalizing we're we're
setting up the programs or funding the
programs to treat
excessive
which is to say abuse I think this only
confuses things and
should be declined
okay but I think that they already have
that program
and I have no idea what it's called
oops representative you said and and
most specifically this is policy this is
this has nothing to do in our purview
period
but it it does if we
we're not using the name that they've
already got that's not what we have for
though representative we're here for tax
policy Revenue we're not here for word
smithing policy issues no no but that
yeah I I agree with you on one level but
on another if this name already exists
okay okay
but we do need to change the reference
the reference 24
uh 318 f 24 to 21. uh Madam chairman yes
um those uh changes which were provided
by representative Ames have been
Incorporated so oh in yours okay so
you'll see that part of it doesn't
happen okay great yes I did not want I
did not have the ability to talk with
them to figure out what was going on
because they always disappeared before
we got halfway through the day
um
and but trust fund trust fund was in the
original language
it was a trust fund it is no longer a
trust fund they just took out trust
but they mean different things
all right where are you in your
amendment I am lost
in the
on you can't see trust in there in the
amendment that belongs to to uh
on
legislative Services because they
repealed and reenacted the whole thing
okay I hate it when they do that I know
well but
what it said before on line 20 uh three
was she'll continue to make
distributions from the trust fund
but there they took out the trust fund
concept somewhere else when they when
hunt redid it
okay well it's
is 12 28 okay as it stands
is 12 20 Amendment 12 28 okay as it
stands
no
they're going to have to I mean for one
thing you're going to make me go back
and get them to put abuse into instead
of use which doesn't take very long
it's just a search and replace
okay well I guess
let's take a straw vote on do we
think that we should adopt 12 28. I
haven't
there's some other wordsmithing stuff in
here that I will Madam chair void and
then then there's the timing issue which
starts in under dual youth certificates
on the second page
and they wanted to change the 18 months
to one year as I said I didn't have a
chance to discuss this stuff with them
and he's not here this afternoon
so
um it seems to me what we've got for
others who think they understand the
timing of this process on we've got the
regular cannabis places getting their
rules finished that rules started
a year within a year and a half after
after they start
we need more and
I did it I'm sorry I'm not sure about
that side of the room I apologize
I've got one
that's the new handout though is
actually a different topic so we need to
continue and finish the Omni
representative Army discussion first
before we go to this if we if if that's
true and I think that's true that's that
the regular cannabis places license on
rules are going to be written starting a
year and a half after
we
after we approve this
going through jail car
I think that means
um so then we shouldn't give them a half
year
extra time
and this this one they're saying no
later than
one year instead of 18 months
but if anybody else remembers I remember
something about three they wanted three
years or something though am I the only
one the the agency wants three years
until a time that they are
actively licensing people
on and
the agency wants I think it's a year I
wish some of them were here but on a
year and a half
um before they they put the rules into
form to hand to jail car and start
fighting that battle
on
if that's true for all the other
marijuana growers and manufacturers it
ought to be true for these guys too
rather than getting a head start of six
months
if
anybody else remember the timing
no that's until they start licensing and
starting to operate we're not getting
anywhere so I I wonder if we could talk
about 1228 represent almie's bill with
the understanding use is going to go
back to abuse
well there's that excuse and I was
trying to bring up the other issues in
here uh Roman numeral three in Roman
numeral four will come out
now because Rochford passed
on
what's still valid in here
uh that comes out if it passes what's
still valid in here is going to be all
of my errata that separate The Liquor
Commission from any cannabis Commission
now Madam chair is use goes to abuse
sections three and four are out
is that right uh
section on section 2 is out because it's
in the spilsbury now section three is
out because it's as you call it word
processing except for the part I was
just trying to talk about which is do
they get a heads
the earlier's time
than uh
then the the rest in
developing the rule making process
um
and I can't remember the timing now I'm
sorry uh section
uh you know I can't bring that paper
towards the next section
on Madam chair yes
whoever's talking to the Madam chair
for the sake of expediency I've read
through this my colleague has read
through this there's no nothing in here
but policy changes why yes there's
nothing in here but policy changes we're
renaming the liquor and can cannabis
commission to the Cannabis commission
that's not how this is written and it's
not how it was sent over to us to look
at the Tax and Revenue issues and we
could go on for the next eight hours or
we could press forward with this my
suggestion is we take straw poll on this
amendment and go on to the next straw
poll after we discuss the next amendment
I would like to accomplish this really
is an appropriate tone I've never been
at Ways and Means where someone has
talked to us like that I'm not talking
to anyone like that I'm addressing the
chair
all right guys
um I I hear all sides here and I
understand we're all tired it's been a
long day
um tone is noted we let's keep this
professional and respectful we do have
enough information I think in front of
us on the uh representative almi's
Amendment 1228 so I think it's in order
to just get a feel for where we are with
a straw vote
um so let me just do that and then if we
need further excuse me I want to reply
to that here the issue of whether the
Liquor Commission is called liquor and
cannabis is a legal Jeopardy question
okay and if we send it over the Senate
like that and the Senate passed it there
is is a major difficulty if we get a
president who doesn't like cannabis
for our entire Liquor Commission and if
I can respond to that no no I'm sorry
let's let's stop we're not going back
and forth on this okay we will now do a
straw vote on whether we should pass
1228 as part of our committee Amendment
all those in favor of the items in 1228
raise your hand
don't understand the amendment so I
can't vote
hey yes
okay okay so raise your hand if you
support still the vote okay anyone okay
all those opposed I'm not voting I'm not
voting either okay
please count
two six seven eight
huh
all right so
representative fellows
so
on this amendment 1228 we're going to
cross out we're not we want to not
include the first section
section it says section two on line
three and we're going to we don't need
on page two we want to delete
the Dual use certificate part that's in
here because we just we already approved
um representative roquefort's
change to that and just on the issue of
abuse and use my recollection is that
the terminology people like using now is
misuse they don't like the word abuse
and they want misuse
so that this would be substance misuse
prevention but maybe someone can check
on that we went over this we've been
going over this for a solid 30 minutes
it did not have strong support
um if half of you didn't even vote so I
you know
I'm not sure this is something we can
cooperate into our committee Amendment
yes represented all me yes I believe
that the issue of liquor and cannabis
fund is
really important and I'll bring in a
floor Amendment if I have to on that I I
can understand the position of not using
their
um their language they're going to have
to go
to the Senate and try to get that in
but on there is another timing issue in
there which I've admitted I don't fully
understand but I don't agree with what
they did if it gives them an advantage
over the other marijuana places
yeah and you know and that is always an
option too is once we get this committee
Amendment done today if there's some
remaining things you know certainly all
welcome to do your own floor Amendment
or maybe we can even come together and
do that so okay okay so we'll move along
from that piece and now we will go to
the spillsbury and do set Amendment 1227
should we skip over the abuse question
or that's not enough it's not an
amendment because we didn't seem to have
enough support
um
oh good question because that's what it
should be well apparently apparently the
original Bill well unless it's unchanged
what we've got right here it says
Substance Abuse Prevention Recovery Fund
established so when you establish it
that's when it gets its title yeah and
and we didn't have really good
discussion amongst the committee on that
nomenclature
um and again that's going back to the
policy stuff so now we're starting to
get murky there
um
I don't think they should have changed
it on her Amendment
because this right here says it's
established and says its title gotcha
okay well it's in there we know it's
there and over time we certainly can
tweak things you know as you know this
we're just we're creating a construct
right now a whole new construct and
what's not going to be perfect but we're
going to get it off the ground and then
we'll be able to tweak it often along
the way okay representative spilsberry
would you be open to discussing or
walking us through this amendment please
thank you
yes thank you madam chair
um
so what OLS has done here
is you can see this is now quite bulky
um
what do we have 21 Pages that's because
we had made amendments to enough
different places in section seven of the
underlying Bill section 7 of HB 639 is
the one that sets up the whole construct
of cannabis regulation and it carries
from page 3 to page 22 of the main bill
so that's essentially what you have here
before they get to that
you'll see on page one
in
lines one through seven
this amendment makes the corrections to
the citations that representative Ames
had found so
online 5 f24 has become F21 and online 7
f25 has become F22
this is on the first page of this new
Amendment uh 1227 h
purely a citation cleanup
the next Amendment which covers lines 9
through 13th is the same
this one on line 13 changes the citation
from 318 F20
5 to f 22.
okay
so the guts of this is then starting on
line 17.
all of chapter 318 f is restated
and that continues
all the way to page 21.
now I'm I'm just going to jump past that
and then come back to it on page 21 you
see the another separate Amendment
and that's the one that made the change
of the term fiscal year to biennium
but if we've had a straw poll
that we're going to incorporate
representative almi's Appropriations
language
this amendment on page 21 will be struck
it's superseded
okay so that's that's part of what
representative almi and I will work at
with OLX could you just give us the line
you're saying page 21 line page 21.
lines 5 through 15. yep
the language in
um
12 23 in 12 20
24.
I believe it is
so house Amendment 1224 h
will give us the language that
supersedes this
and they'll be Blended together into
men
12 23.
yeah
it is yes you're absolutely correct
thank you
1223 which relates to the Appropriations
yeah
uh yes representative
he's going through it line by line right
now and hopefully he'll show us that
thank you thank you
so okay so the guts of what we have done
now lies in this uh long amendment that
begins on page one
line 15.
and it's simply been
um
incorporated into a restated
318f
so
I'm I'm looking at quite a bit of this
at the same time you are for the first
time but let's uh let's find it
so we're double checking that the second
thing that you want to do before was to
get rid of that whole opt-in out thing
oh thing that's gone right that's fixed
let's find that I saw it on a computer
screen I'm not seeing it on paper for
the first time
hard to do this
without
page 11 12. it's it's going to be f11
page 12.
yes so the language is on the top of
on line one
so this restores the language of HB 639
which says municipality May enact an
ordinance prohibiting or limiting IE opt
out
the amendment had permitting
and that's now been restored to the
original version of HB 639
now we want to go to F21
foreign
so F21
begins on the bottom of page 18.
and
the amendment
is changing the language that begins on
page 19
line 17.
this is the 15 50 for education
reincorporating reinstating the language
which instructs the dra to make the
calculation of what the net swept
requirement is for each municipality
so you'll recognize that language from
the original HP 630 where can you point
to that language where is that yes sure
on page 19. yep
um the lines 17 to 23 so this is perfect
five that Roman numeral five b one
and what it does here is it it it
takes the same first several words 50
percent of remaining funds shall
and everything beyond the word shall
restores what was in HP 639
okay
represent what yes I'm confused with the
number of amendments we've discussed and
the changes uh your language and this
amendment on line six has two million
dollars here of appropriate the
commission for the cost of
administration of this chapter did we
stay with the two million or were we
willing to change that so so this
language will be superseded by
representative homies amendment 1224h in
that relevant part
and her language regarding the
allocations will be eliminated
right so we're blending
my life
okay
after our discussion when we broke for
lunch
my cult from DHHS approached me
and pointed out that our Amendment
had de-linked
the funding allocation
in Roman numeral five b three
and that is on page 19 line 30.
from
the provision on the next page on page
20 line 10.
through 16. so let me just explain that
very briefly
the bill HB 639 includes this provision
on page 2318 F 22 which creates a fund
the Substance Abuse Prevention and
Recovery Fund the original language of
639 had a reference to that
and so we've reincorporated that I'm
sure everyone will agree if now if you
go back to page 19 I'll show you where
it's Incorporated
on page 19
lines 30 and 31
10 of remaining funds are 25 million
whichever is less
shall be credited to we've changed the
reference Now by inserting the Substance
Abuse Prevention and Recovery Fund in
RSA 318f22 so this specifically
designates that fund
as the repository for this 10 or 25
million whichever is less
does that make sense what was that okay
representative
good thank you
um so can you just remind me I know
you're putting it back to the bill
language can you remind me what it had
changed to to it was just unclear where
the money was going before uh
great question so
on page 22
let me tell everyone has that so the
main bill on page 22
on lines nine and ten
said simply 10 shall be allocated to the
Substance Abuse Prevention recovery
funds established by RSA 318 F22 and
that's a direct reference to the
um
section
that's just below on lines 19 to 25. 318
F22 creates this Substance Abuse
Prevention Recovery Fund
now
what Roman numeral
um what what the earlier provision the
one on line nine and ten
allocating the 10 percent did not do is
say for what use are these funds being
made it turns out that 318 F22 doesn't
really get into
what they're going to be used or spent
for it just goes into the mechanics
of
you know how the months how the funds
are handled talks about State Treasurer
and and deposits into the fund
so so this basically Blends the two it
it keeps the language of the two sets
Pillsbury Amendment that states
what the funds are used for
and
would you take a question representative
Platt yes I see two million appearing
twice and are they the same or different
first page is on page first one is page
19 line six sum of two millions here by
appropriate the commission the casa
administration of this chapter Etc and
then I go to page
line 12 the sum of 22 million for the
biennium June 30th 25 is here but
probably the liquor and cannabis
commission for deposit on the Cannabis
fund how they're the same or different
and once the administration is one of
fun
okay
um representative Platt I didn't keep up
with you so I see the the 2 million
um
for the biennium
line six of page 19. you have 2 million
hereby appropriate at the commission for
across the administration of this
chapter got that one and then the second
one is online
page 21 line 12 the sum of 2 million for
the biennium is here appropriate the
liquor cannabis commission for
depositing the Cannabis fund okay so
this is an appropriation provision at
the end and both of these are superseded
by representative Ami's Amendment
okay so I I think we finally got the
allocation
provisions
reconciled between the two versions
representative Elber I just want to
clarify that on page 19
somewhere in uh
Romans 5
are we including startup costs
in here because it says after deduction
deducting appropriation charges for the
administration of this chapter where
does it say anything about
having to return from the commission
to the the state those startup funds
sure so the answer to that
is and and remember this has changed by
representative Ami's Amendment but if
you look at line
six to eight
that provision Roman numeral three ends
with a sentence said some shall be a
charge against the fund
that's the phrasing that basically means
they're borrowing from the fund and they
will restore the funds when they have
earned them when they've got a
sufficient amount of tax revenue
and one other quick question we've got
the substance abuse and prevention
Substance Abuse Prevention and I assume
that somebody is going to need to get
the language to be consistent between
substance abuse and substance use or
substance misuse so this bill throughout
uses the term substance abuse
and I think they're consistent yeah yeah
and we're going to keep it like that
although if representative Almy wants to
do a floor Amendment or others want to
do that to change it throughout the
entire bill you can certainly do that or
at another time but it sounds like we
need to discuss what is the right
verbiage there because it seems like we
have a little bit of discussion uh
representative I sense that we may be in
agreement with this with the changes
that uh Incorporated by representative
almi into the Doucet spillsbury
Amendment before us and if that's the
case maybe it's time for us ruffle well
we have a few other items notably the
tax rate and the make sure the
definition of what the tax is upon
exactly so now if you'll go to page 20
of our new Amendment
and you look at line 17
318 F 23
sets up the whole tax and that carries
on to page 21 line three
so this is a collection of changes that
we have already discussed and I believe
we achieved near consensus over setting
aside the question of the rate itself
but this is the same language we've been
looking at
with two changes that reflect the
discussion we had this morning about
representative fellow's proposed
amendment and the language that was
provided by representative Ames and
you'll see that specifically with the
addition of Roman numeral four
and six Roman numeral four is on lines
28 to 30.
Roman numeral six is lines 33
uh carrying over to the next page those
two are new language based on this
morning's discussion
all done
representative Leighton
um thank you madam chair I just wanted
to note that um if we're using the
entire Army Amendment 1223h it would
also replace the change in the
allocation of those tax funds right and
I'm sorry I didn't make that clear
because we agreed that that Center
portion of Representative almies would
fall away okay and this would Prevail
thank you
thank you okay so now
this amendment We Believe does the stuff
we wanted to do so let's just take a
straw vote on amendment to read the
language that got added in yet
representative sure while you're reading
um
oh boy so many pieces of paper floating
around here
uh
there were
two very minor changes that uh
representative Ames and I agreed on
in Roman numeral four we had previously
said
the commission may determine
the transfer price we've changed it to
Shell ascertain
in Roman numeral six
we struck two words I don't have them in
front of me at the moment but it said
something like you know before and in
the future
just a second I've got it
we struck the words expected or
experienced so now it just says the
commission shall study the efficacy
hey I guess 12.5 as a winner have been
the whole thing as a winner
I first of all I can't believe how much
work you guys did awesome job
representative Ames and spilsbury and
Doucette in particular have spent so
much time on this thank you all right so
before us we have straw poll vote on
Amendment 1227 H if you're in favor
raise your hand
all those posts
only got two but I'm missing someone
someone's gone okay so we have a strong
majority there thank you thank you thank
you so now what we'll do is we'll stop
the work session we will ask
representative spilsberry
and whoever wants to join him to combine
12 27 12 23 1217
into one committee Amendment thank you
we'll wait glad to
representative Elber
thank you madam chair
um just going back to my my little chart
here
um if we are going to have the 12 and a
half percent
rate then we need to be taxing on at
least 35 million dollars to be able to
cover
the cost of operations that's number one
number two
um whenever we get around to trying to
cover the 15 20 million however much
that's going to be in startup costs we
need to figure that many more years and
that much more Revenue before that gets
uh covered again and
um
I
think
that telling people that this is the
rate now but we're going to need to
raise it in three years because it's not
going to cover what we needed to cover
is going to be a pretty hard sell
especially if it turns out that for the
first couple of years the prices go up
but then they drop as the program ramps
up and our revenue is diminishing so I'm
wondering whether we need to think about
whether this is the right approach thank
you
well and you know certainly there'll be
a majority report hopefully that comes
out of this committee but there also
could be a Minority Report that could
express those concerns and I really love
the amendment we have here which talks
about them coming back to us and
explaining what we're what they're doing
so we'll keep an eye on it and we'll
make amends as we need to
we are in recess for our work session
um and we're going to await the full
committee Amendment merging the three
amendments into one
and then we will go into executive
session as soon as that's hot off the
press
so we'll get it done today
we're in recess from our work session
and then we will hope as soon as that
combined Amendment comes back to us we
will exec it and then tomorrow I would
really love to have the majority of men
blurb and the minority blurb so that we
can review them make sure they're
factually correct and then get them to
the committee assistant and get them to
the house clerk because they're putting
together all the moving parts for next
week's calendar
I don't know because we haven't taken
the vote on the final final
what is like the really the absolute
deadline for getting a report in I mean
you'd like it by tomorrow but if it's by
Wednesday is that yeah but again you
know keep in mind I have to review it
you know so it has goes like yeah
but if a couple of people are going to
get together
then
and the reason we're not here the reason
we're here today and not tomorrow is
because I had the doctor's appointment
as you remember so yes yes we're trying
to get this done so we can you know
drive here once basically
um yeah I would love to get it tomorrow
anytime tomorrow would be great just so
that the vice chair and I can read them
and make sure everything's just
factually correct and then we'll send it
to committee assistant who sends it to
the clerk a little bit more time we have
it just helps but yeah absolutely by
four o'clock on Wednesday is deadline
thank you awesome so we're just gonna
sit here now and go get some cookies or
something and hang out
I don't know I mean they've been working
on this pretty closely and there's no
one else in this building except for us
and house finance so we are taking
priority I think so I don't think it'll
be too bad
do you want a definite time to be back
do you want to give them half an hour
well we can try if you could yeah
definitely be back at quarter of five is
that right yeah definitely be back by
then
um but maybe sooner yeah sounds good
yeah thanks for keeping me on track
foreign
so we got our merged Amendment back
including representative Rose shirt's
language and representative almie's
language
but in the process they misunderstood
the way representative almies would be
incorporated
so where we were agreeing to the first
part
of F21 relating to the Appropriations
and we were not disturbing the
allocations
and then we were agreeing to the
Appropriations at the end of the bill
instead of they didn't understand us
correctly so instead of modifying only
the first part of the third part they
deleted the middle part completely so
the version we got back lacks all of
Roman numeral five under F21 with the
allocations so we've hit reset
they're in the process
I'm figuring 15 minutes since they've
already seen the language it shouldn't
be quite as long a review period as we
normally have to wait
let's paste it back in
everything else checks out so far but
I'm going to sit here quietly and look
again
yes ma'am
good afternoon good evening
we will now open the executive session
on House Bill 639 and the chair will
recognize representative spilsbury for a
motion
thank you madam chair I move
OTP
on Amendment
2023-1231 h
to HB 639 is there a second
representative Ames seconds it would you
like to speak to your motion yes thank
you
so
um we have just reviewed this and we had
seen on our previous look that uh
all of the provisions
from
representative roachford's Amendment are
now on page 10.
dual use certificates starting on line
10.
and you'll see when you look at uh Roman
numerals two and three on line 16 18
that then there's no longer a reference
to the ten thousand dollar application
fee or to the ninety thousand dollar uh
set up fee for a dual license holder
okay
on
on page 18
near the bottom
you'll see online 30 that uh
section F21 cannabis fund established
begins and Roman numeral one and two are
unchanged
so over to page 19
Roman numerals three and four
incorporate the representative almi's
amendment to put in 15 million dollars
and five hundred thousand dollars
respectively for the biennium in each
case
Roman numeral five starting on line 11
and going to the bottom of the page and
on to the next page has been restored
has been found and so that gives us our
allocation
that includes the change we made on line
to specifically tie the 10 percent for
DHHS to the Substance Abuse Prevention
and Recovery Fund
next Amendment over on page 20.
starting on line 17
section F 23 has been
changed to now be called the excise tax
and online 18 and excise tax
the other change in that Roman numeral
one is 12.5 percent
on line 21
and the other changes to section F 23
are the addition of subsection Roman
numeral four
and subsection Roman numeral six
so the Roman numeral 4 has to do with
ascertaining the intermediate transfer
price in a vertically integrated
operation
and Roman numeral 6 has to do with the
periodic reports we would get from the
commission regarding uh the rate level
and potential future adjustments
finally
over on page 21
all of the Appropriations section 33
which starts on line seven and runs to
the end on line 22.
has been
replaced with the language from
representative Army's amendments so that
it now
appropriates
100 000 for the fiscal year 2025.
7 million for the year of the Year
ending 20 June 30th 24 another 8 million
for the fiscal year ending June 30th 25
and then finally in Roman numeral 4 the
500 000 appropriation for substance use
prevention is a biennial
appropriation through June 30th 2025. I
believe that covers them all
thank you so much I strongly uh want to
just thank everybody for the patience
and cooperation I think we've really
improved the bill greatly
outstanding job everyone yes everyone
but we haven't taken a vote yet so why
don't we uh are there any comments
before we move forward on the vote
sing on the clerk will call the roll
yes
no
representative yes yes
yes
no
the vote being 16 to 4 the amendment
number 1231 H passes chair recognizes
representative spilsbury for another
motion
thank you madam chair I move uh ought to
pass as amended on HB 639
is there a second
representative am seconds any further
comments on your motion representative
spilsbury
I think we've said enough okay would
anyone else like to speak representative
almi
you I just realized when we got in there
that we were keeping cannabis on
liquor and cannabis can commission I do
think that the Liquor Commission is
quite opposed to this I am trying to get
through to them to find out if that is
still true
um and if so I'm going to want to put in
a floor Amendment and I hope
I will send a map a email around to
everybody about the result of trying to
discuss it with the Liquor Commission
and and hope that people would agree in
under those circumstances to replace all
of those names
which are found all over the bill
all the comments
I'm not seeing none of the clerk will
call the rule representative janigan yes
represent ulery yes representative yes
representative Pillsbury yes
representative plaid votes yes
representative Leon yes representative
yes representative orrs yes
representative yes representative malmy
yes representative Ames yes
representative Southworth no
uh representative Malloy yes
represent rung yes
representative fellows no
representative Bolton yes
Representative elberger no
representative liply
representative Smith yes and the chair
yes 16 to 4.
the vote being 16-4 the ought to pass as
amended motion carries and uh
representative spilsbury would you be
comfortable doing the majority report
sure will there be a Minority Report
there will be a Minority Report by
representative fellows love to have
those sometime tomorrow before midnight
so that we can get those in good order
to the clerk and the committee assistant
yes representative Phyllis
right here
the clerk has the form
um and you can use the form or you can
email it in whatever format you want to
I did I did send it out electronically
earlier yeah I'm just basically just
this is a Minority Report on House Bill
639 and the minority would be I you know
whatever your motion would be would it
be just ought to pass would it be itl
would it be retain whatever well not
retain but whatever your
position is okay yeah
and then if it's not in the proper
format the committee assistant will help
us make sure it's proper that's why we
have need the extra time just to make
sure we're all set okay guys uh we will
now close the executive session on House
Bill 639 and I thank you all very very
very much you guys did an awesome
awesome job I look forward to seeing you
next week
um the only thing we have I think is how
session on April 6 very very important
day that is crossover we will be taking
up this bill our other second committee
bills as well as HB 1 2 and 25. so we'll
see you then
thank you
yeah we have House Bill 446 or something
like that it was uh representative
ulery's bill regarding the um
oplc dedicated fund remember that bill
that that's going to come up
those will be on the floor on April 6.
I'm sorry can you turn on your thing so
I can hear you when do you anticipate us
having another committee meeting oh
um I hope everyone heard me announce
that after we get through crossover that
next week I think everyone should take a
vacation so the week of April 10th I
will schedule nothing and then obviously
the week after that we're going to have
to start scheduling some Senate bills
but I think
we only have like 12 13 bills so it's
not too bad
yeah I know we could but hopefully we
don't have to we'll see I haven't read a
single one so we'll see what we get um
but I want to make sure you guys have
some r r because you guys have worked so
hard
good awesome yes representative balmy
yeah
yeah them bills if anybody here has got
a bill that went over to the Senate
yes yes and they aren't always really
good at
telling people
so trying to look up the Senate calendar
every week might be a good idea
if you have a bill hostage
okay guys great job thank you to our
substitutes appreciate your being here
we know the sacrifice you made thank you
yeah yeah thank you